Hey everybody, so this is one thing that I'm sure a lot of people are wondering. I've always wondered it. I feel like I'm going to learn a ton today. I'm really looking forward to it. But, you know, when you do something like use Google Maps or Waze or any of these, even people who remember MapQuest, you know, it generates this path. And, you know, that is just really fascinating if you think about it. There's an unbelievable amount, an enormous network of roads. It manages to figure out how to do that. It takes into account speed limits. It just seems like there's extraordinary complexity there. We're actually going to not only cover that, but even take it to the next level, where in this case, what if you were driving, let's say, a UPS truck or something, and you
大家好，这是很多人肯定会好奇的一个问题。我一直都很好奇。我觉得今天能学到很多东西，我非常期待。但是，你知道，当你使用谷歌地图或Waze之类的工具时，甚至对于那些还记得MapQuest的人来说，它会生成一条路径。如果你仔细想想，这真的很神奇。道路网络极其庞大，简直难以置信。它竟然能算出该怎么走。它还考虑了限速。这看起来似乎极其复杂。我们不仅要讨论这一点，还要更进一步，比如，如果你开着一辆UPS卡车之类的车，而且你
have a whole host of places you have to go to, or even maybe you have a list of errands you need to run. How do we actually do that efficiently? And I think it's a fascinating, fascinating topic. We're going to dive deep into it. I'm so lucky that we have Parker Woodward here, who is the route expert at Route4Me and has a ton of experience in this field. So thanks for coming on the show, Parker.
有一大堆地方要去，或者你有一份需要完成的杂事清单。我们该如何高效地做到这一点呢？我认为这是一个非常非常迷人的话题。我们将深入探讨它。我很幸运能请到Route4Me的路线专家Parker Woodward，他在这个领域拥有丰富的经验。感谢你来到节目，Parker。
Yeah, thanks, Jason. And don't worry, people still actually use MapQuest. Oh, really? I was wondering, actually, when I said that. So it exists, right? Well, I've seen it exists. People are still using it. And people are using a host of other things to plan the routes.
是的，谢谢你，Jason。别担心，人们实际上还在使用MapQuest。哦，真的吗？我刚才说的时候还在想呢。所以它还存在，对吧？嗯，我见过它还在。人们确实还在用它。而且人们还在使用许多其他工具来规划路线。
We had a customer who actually planned the routes on cocktail napkins at happy hour. So we've had, we've seen a little bit of everything. Oh, nice. Very cool. That's awesome. So yeah, how did you, you know, I think this is going to be really interesting because, you know, route expert is a title that seems to be one that like is out of reach for a lot of people. Like a lot of people don't see what is the path that I can take from maybe my algebra two course right now to route expert. And so it'd be amazing to hear your kind of story. You know, how did you kind of get to where you are and what was that whole path like? Sure. So I took maybe a non-traditional path and I was in the entrepreneurial world and studied in college, actually something totally different. And it was more about
我们有一位客户甚至在欢乐时光用鸡尾酒餐巾纸来规划路线。所以我们什么都见过。哦，不错。太酷了。太棒了。那么，你是怎么……我觉得这会非常有趣，因为“路线专家”这个头衔对很多人来说似乎遥不可及。很多人看不出从现在的代数二课程到成为路线专家之间有什么路径。所以，听听你的故事会很棒。你是怎么走到今天这一步的，整个过程是怎样的？当然。我走的是一条非传统的道路，我曾在创业圈工作，大学里学的其实是完全不同的东西。更多是关于
conservation and biology and animal behavior and different types of systems, you know, in comparison to route planning. And I was always fascinated with energy and conservation and efficiency and happened to really stumble across this opportunity with Route for me. And at the time I was doing kind of transitioning into the fascinating world of the web and software and building software. And so I just found Route for me and got involved with the two co-founders. They started in 2009. Really interesting story there as well. Very entrepreneurial.
保护生物学、动物行为学以及各种类型的系统，你知道，这与路线规划相比。我一直对能源、保护和效率很着迷，偶然间发现了Route4Me这个机会。当时我正处于向迷人的网络、软件和软件开发领域转型的过程中。所以我发现了Route4Me并与两位联合创始人取得了联系。他们于2009年开始创业。那里的故事也非常有趣。非常有创业精神。
One of them was kind of looking for an apartment and they didn't really have, you know, an app back then that would help them on the mobile phone to kind of build an efficient route when you're going to see 5, 10, 15, 20 places. So you're spending a lot of time going around. So our CEO and founder, Dan Cassis, built the first mobile app that would optimize and plan a route for you so it could be efficient. So he was apartment hunting at the time. And his buddy from college, George Shagalov, he got involved and they took it to the next level and they just started listening to customers more and more. And I got involved.
其中一个人当时在找公寓，而那时手机上并没有什么应用程序能帮你在要去5、10、15、20个地方时规划出一条高效的路线。所以你得花很多时间在路上绕来绕去。于是我们的首席执行官兼创始人Dan Cassis开发了第一个移动应用程序，它可以为你优化和规划路线，从而提高效率。他当时正在找公寓。他大学时的好友George Shagalov也加入了进来，他们将公司提升到了一个新的水平，并开始越来越多地倾听客户的意见。然后我就加入了。
And, you know, next thing you know, you just start to learn about this. So it's sort of a burgeoning field. It's if someone's interested in becoming a routing expert, a lot of it is about dealing with people and product and also processes. And you'll be amazed at these companies that they're trying to figure it out too. And so as you get exposure to more and more about how to implement these solutions and how to really make efficiency gains, you just learn along the way. So I think that's the best way to learn anything is to just go out and do it. Yeah, that's really, really good advice. And it's super interesting. We have a lot of folks who have a variety of different degrees or maybe didn't go to college and have a different background. Maybe they have a trade. And so they feel like,
然后，你懂的，你很快就开始了解这个领域了。这是一个正在蓬勃发展的领域。如果有人对成为路线专家感兴趣，很大程度上是关于如何处理人、产品和流程。你会惊讶地发现，这些公司也在努力弄清楚这一点。当你接触到越来越多关于如何实施这些解决方案以及如何真正实现效率提升的知识时，你就会在过程中不断学习。所以我认为学习任何东西最好的方法就是直接去实践。是的，这建议真的非常好。而且非常有趣。我们有很多拥有各种不同学位的人，或者可能没上过大学、背景不同的人。也许他们有一门手艺。所以他们觉得，
how do I really get started in this field? And one thing we tell a lot of folks is a startup or a smaller company is a really good way to get your foot in the door because many of them will, you know, have a real person look at every resume. Whereas if you send your resume off to, you know, some giant tech company, you know, they probably have some automated system. Your resume might literally not be seen by a human eye, right? But smaller companies that are in your area, you will get a chance to really impress them. Yeah, they definitely have systems and software in place. And I think there's even software that you can actually engage and kind of beef up your
我该如何真正进入这个领域呢？我们告诉很多人的一件事是，初创公司或较小的公司是让你入门的好地方，因为他们中的许多人会安排真人查看每一份简历。而如果你把简历发给那些大型科技公司，他们可能有一套自动化系统。你的简历可能根本不会被人类看到，对吧？但你所在地区的较小公司，你将有机会真正给他们留下深刻印象。是的，他们肯定有系统和软件。而且我认为甚至有一些软件可以让你参与并加强你的
resume so it gets beyond the bots. So it's an interesting world. And it's one of those things, if someone's really looking to get started in this, there's nothing really holding you back to kind of say, hey, I want to go do this. And don't be afraid of the nose. Like you might get 10 nose from even a small company says, hey, we can't do that right now or anything like that. But try to look to provide value.
简历，这样它就能绕过机器人。所以这是一个有趣的世界。如果有人真的想开始做这件事，没有什么能阻挡你，你可以说，嘿，我想做这个。不要害怕被拒绝。你可能会被小公司拒绝10次，他们说，嘿，我们现在做不到，或者类似的话。但要试着去提供价值。
You know, if you want to learn, you know, routing and route optimization, which I think is a wonderful space, because I really, truly believe we're helping to save the planet and save the world, especially as more and more carbon emissions are being emitted. You know, more and more vehicles are going on the road. Hopefully we're getting towards a electrical, you know, fleet, you know, in more and more electrical fleets. At the same time, if someone wants to learn this, just go out and do it. Start contacting companies and just say, hey, I want to kind of learn the process and start adding value. And there's no reason someone couldn't go out and
你知道，如果你想学习路线规划和路线优化，我认为这是一个很棒的领域，因为我真心相信我们正在帮助拯救地球，拯救世界，尤其是随着碳排放量越来越多。你知道，越来越多的车辆上路了。希望我们能走向电动车队，你知道，越来越多的电动车队。同时，如果有人想学习这个，直接去做就行了。开始联系公司，说，嘿，我想学习这个流程并开始增加价值。没有人不能走出去，去
just find other companies that need these types of solutions to help them implement them. So it could be almost your little company that you could start just off the top of my head, just to get some experience on your own. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. So you were studying biology, which actually gives me a lot of hope. My older son is really, really into biology. Actually, I take it back. Maybe hope isn't the right way of saying it. If he wants to be a biologist, that's amazing. I'm not going to hold him back from that. But it seems like there's a chance that he could study biology and still end up in tech. So I'll hold out for that. But yeah, you're studying computational biology. Can you describe a little more detail how that got into route for me? So did you graduate and then you started the job hunt or while you were studying this, you met those folks? How did all of that work? Yeah. So as I was studying through college, I was doing things like consulting on the side. I was actually building websites. So I was just finding work actually on what is now Upwork. And so that was really kind of my side hustle. I was even bartending, you know, through
寻找其他需要这些解决方案的公司来帮助他们实施。所以这几乎可以成为你自己的小公司，你可以凭空开始，只是为了获得一些自己的经验。是的，这非常有道理。你当时在学生物学，这实际上给了我很多希望。我的大儿子非常非常喜欢生物学。其实，我收回刚才的话。也许“希望”这个词用得不对。如果他想成为一名生物学家，那太棒了。我不会阻止他。但看起来他确实有可能学习生物学，最后却进入了科技行业。所以我对此抱有期待。但你学的是计算生物学。你能详细描述一下你是如何进入Route4Me的吗？你是毕业后开始找工作，还是在学习期间遇到了那些人？这一切是怎么运作的？是的。我在大学学习期间，会在业余时间做咨询。我当时在建网站。所以我实际上是在现在的Upwork上找工作。那确实是我的副业。我甚至在大学期间做过调酒师，
college and everything like that. And, you know, I actually got the opportunity. I saw something to do a little consulting work or route for me. And, you know, I made a quick video resume just to try to stand above and, and sent that off and just said, Hey, I'm really interested in the work that you're doing and would love to be of assistance. And next thing you know, it was a startup. So I'm wearing a lot of different hats, helping out in a lot of different areas, really making an impact. I felt, which was amazing coming out of school. I think you always wanted to make an impact really, really quickly. And, you know, so it was a little bit of a non-traditional path, maybe even a little what some might consider risky,
等等。然后，我确实得到了机会。我看到了一些可以为Route4Me做点咨询工作的机会。我做了一个简短的视频简历，试图脱颖而出，然后把它发了过去，说，嘿，我对你们正在做的工作非常感兴趣，希望能提供帮助。然后你就知道，那是一家初创公司。所以我身兼数职，在许多不同的领域提供帮助，真的产生了影响。我觉得这很棒，刚出校门就能做到。我想你总是希望尽快产生影响。所以，这确实是一条非传统的道路，甚至有些人可能认为有点冒险，
you know, working for this company that, you know, wasn't this big name brand company, but it's been growing more and more and it's a leader in its space. And it's just been wonderful to work for a company that really has that family company feel. And so that's how I got started. And then I just rolled up my sleeves and went to work. So that was my experience was just how can I help and make things better? And that's really what Route4Me is about is making routes better, making them more efficient, making businesses better, making people's lives just easier. You would be amazed at how many people are literally pulling their hair out just trying to get routes planned for their drivers or even themselves. So it's a really, really great feeling to go home at the end of the day and say, hey, I help people.
为这家不是大品牌的公司工作，但它一直在成长，并且是该领域的领导者。能在一家真正有家庭公司感觉的公司工作真是太好了。这就是我开始的方式。然后我就卷起袖子开始工作了。这就是我的经历，就是我如何能提供帮助并让事情变得更好？这正是Route4Me的宗旨：让路线更好，让它们更高效，让企业更好，让人们的生活更轻松。你会惊讶地发现，有多少人为了给司机或他们自己规划路线而抓狂。所以，在一天结束时回家说，嘿，我帮助了人们，这种感觉真的非常好。
I help the environment and we all were profitable. So it's really, really cool. Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense. I feel like I'm just plugging route for me right now. No, no, totally makes sense. I feel like I'm just plugging route for me right now. No, no, it's fine. I think, oh, yeah, I think one thing you really touched on is super important is I have a friend who kind of told this joke. He said, you know, I have a PhD from Princeton. And now, you know, I just hit up enter, you know, because it's like, it's like we have this mathematical simulation. And if it doesn't give you the result you want, you run it again. And so he's like, I got, I spent all this time so I could come here and hit up,
我帮助了环境，而且我们都实现了盈利。所以这真的很酷。是的，完全有道理。我觉得我现在就是在为Route4Me做广告。不，不，完全有道理。我觉得我现在就是在为Route4Me做广告。不，不，没关系。我想，哦，是的，我认为你提到的有一点非常重要，我有一个朋友开过这样一个玩笑。他说，你知道，我拥有普林斯顿大学的博士学位。现在，我只是按下回车键，因为我们有一个数学模拟。如果它没有给你想要的结果，你就再运行一次。所以他说，我花了这么多时间，就是为了来到这里按下
enter. And, and it's true. You can, you can kind of feel like so, you know, separated from any type of real world impact when you work at, at a giant company. And it's so nice to, you know, putting on the different hats is a, is a double- edged sword, right? I mean, for sure, you might not want to spend your day trying to find another janitor for the office, but someone has to do that, right? But on the flip side, you, you know, you do get to see something really cultivate and really grow something, whereas, whereas something so, so giant is moving at such a glacial pace, you don't get that same feeling. Yeah, there's not that red tape, which I think really enables the product to evolve and enables you as a person in the company to have a voice. And you have to realize that your voice, even though it's heard, it may not go in the direction that you want it to. And so there's always that learning portion of kind of coming out of school and getting into a job and realizing that you kind of have to get along with people, which is a wonderful thing. And at the same time, working at a company where basically they say, hey, if you want to make an impact, you want to go do this, like go do it, you know,
回车键。这是真的。当你在大公司工作时，你会觉得自己与任何现实世界的影响都隔绝了。身兼数职是一把双刃剑，对吧？当然，你可能不想花一整天时间去为办公室找清洁工，但总得有人做这件事，对吧？但另一方面，你确实能看到某件事真正培育并成长起来，而像那种庞然大物，它的移动速度慢如蜗牛，你不会有那种感觉。是的，没有那种繁文缛节，我认为这确实使产品得以进化，并使你作为公司的一员拥有发言权。你必须意识到，你的声音虽然被听到了，但可能不会朝着你想要的方向发展。所以，从学校出来进入职场，意识到你必须与人相处，这总是一个学习的过程，这是一件美妙的事情。同时，在一家基本上会说“嘿，如果你想产生影响，你想做这个，那就去做吧”的公司工作，
get dry results and just drive it. So it does take a lot of, especially being a company that was born in the cloud. We almost 95% of us work from home and have, which was kind of taboo prior to COVID. And now it's very normal, but you know, I used to almost not mention it. And now it's kind of, you know, I can it to folks, and they're getting along and figuring it out. We had it figured out a long time ago. But to have that motivation to say, hey, I'm going to go do this. I'm going to drive this project. I'm going to actually run with this, and it becomes my little baby.
获得结果并推动它。所以这确实需要很多，特别是一家诞生于云端的公司。我们几乎95%的人都在家办公，这在新冠疫情之前是禁忌。现在这很正常，但我过去几乎不提它。现在，我可以向人们提及，他们也能理解并适应。我们很久以前就解决了这个问题。但拥有那种动力去说，嘿，我要去做这个。我要推动这个项目。我要真正去执行它，它就成了我的小宝贝。
It's a wonderful thing to have, and I think that's rare. You do see it in a lot of organizations, and I think those are organizations that thrive and do really well and kind of figure out, you know, how to get beyond certain inflection points in the business to kind of really take either the product to the next level and serve their customers better. Yeah. Yeah. I think it totally makes sense. It's a huge challenge to keep that drive and that energy as things get really gigantic
这是一种美妙的感觉，我认为这很罕见。你在很多组织中确实能看到这一点，我认为那些蓬勃发展并做得很好的组织，都能弄清楚如何超越业务中的某些拐点，从而将产品提升到一个新的水平，并更好地服务于他们的客户。是的。是的。我认为这完全有道理。随着事情变得非常巨大，保持那种动力和活力是一个巨大的挑战，
and do it in a way where you're not totally federated, where there's at least some kind of organization. It starts with why, you know, why are we doing this? And that's, you know, as Picasso said, and Steve Jobs stole, you know, great artists steal, and I'm stealing that from Simon Sinek, you know, so you have to believe, you have to believe in what you do and why you do it. And then, you And then how you do it and what you do is important. But people buy into that. The why is really important. And so I'm probably a very annoying person at a party to talk to because I'm always talking
并且要以一种不完全分散的方式去做，至少要有一种组织形式。它始于“为什么”，你知道，我们为什么要这样做？正如毕加索所说，史蒂夫·乔布斯窃取了它，伟大的艺术家窃取，我这是从西蒙·斯涅克那里窃取的，所以你必须相信，你必须相信你所做的事情以及你为什么这样做。然后，你所做的方式和你所做的事情很重要。但人们会认同这一点。为什么很重要。所以我在聚会上可能是一个非常烦人的人，因为我总是谈论
about routing and route planning. And they're like, what is this? I'm like, no, we're saving the world. It's really exciting stuff. This is amazing. We've saved the emissions equivalent of 87 million trees. I mean, like who gets to say that? And coming from my background in conservation, you know, and I've made such a huge impact.
路线和路线规划。他们会问，这是什么？我说，不，我们在拯救世界。这真的很令人兴奋。这太神奇了。我们节省了相当于8700万棵树的碳排放量。我的意思是，谁能说出这样的话？而且我有着保护生物学的背景，我产生了如此巨大的影响。
And I'm just so proud of that or to be a part of that. Not like I've been the one to save the trees. But, you know, there's so much opportunity out there too. Yeah, it's interesting how that fit in. You know, people get so wrapped up in the tech that they look at it in this very one dimensional way. But in your case, you were able to see, oh, this is a perfect fit for me, even though most people consider that like an entirely different career. Right. But for you, it's obvious that these things kind of belong together. Yeah. I mean, from the at least my personal perspective is that technology
我为此感到非常自豪，能成为其中的一部分。并不是说我就是那个拯救树木的人。但是，你知道，外面也有很多机会。是的，这很有趣。你知道，人们太沉迷于技术，以至于他们以这种非常单一的方式看待它。但在你的案例中，你能够看到，哦，这对我来说非常合适，尽管大多数人认为这完全是不同的职业。对。但对你来说，显而易见的是，这些事情是属于一起的。是的。我的意思是，至少从我个人的角度来看，技术
is wonderful. It's just, what do we do with it? Like, how do we truly, you know, take it into something that's going to make our lives better? And we have to be careful a little bit, right? Like one of my favorite books is a sapien. So anyone out there listening who hasn't read that one is a brief history of humankind. Yeah. You've all Noel Harris, I believe. Yeah, that's right. He talks about something called a luxury trap, which is really interesting that, you know, eventually every luxury becomes a necessity. And if you think about that from the perspective of just like having email, you know, everyone has to answer email. But at one point that was like a huge luxury. So all these luxuries become necessities. I mean, even just in the COVID world we live in today, the luxury of like having goods, whether they be Uber Eats or just, you know, Instacart or any of these services actually bring you food or just basic necessities. That was a luxury. And now it's become this necessity. And so people are using it more and more. And so it's just interesting how we have to take that technology and balance between, okay, well, how do we make sure that we're also not doing things like killing the environment? And so I really see like that being on the forefront of, hey, we know we need to get to renewable resources. We know that electric's coming, but how do we make sure we're efficient and get to that point? So technology is really interesting in how we can leverage it in so many different ways for the greater good.
是美妙的。只是，我们用它做什么？我们如何真正把它变成能让我们的生活变得更好的东西？我们必须小心一点，对吧？我最喜欢的书之一是《人类简史》。所以任何还没读过那本书的人，那是人类简史。是的，尤瓦尔·赫拉利，我想。是的，没错。他谈到了一种叫做“奢侈品陷阱”的东西，这非常有趣，你知道，最终每一种奢侈品都会变成必需品。如果你从拥有电子邮件的角度来考虑这一点，你知道，每个人都必须回复电子邮件。但曾经那是一个巨大的奢侈。所以所有这些奢侈品都变成了必需品。我的意思是，即使在我们今天生活的疫情世界中，拥有商品（无论是Uber Eats还是Instacart，或者任何这些实际上为你送食物或基本必需品的服务）的奢侈。那曾经是一种奢侈。现在它已经变成了必需品。所以人们越来越多地使用它。所以有趣的是，我们必须利用这种技术，并在我们如何确保我们不会做像破坏环境这样的事情之间取得平衡。所以我真的认为，站在前沿，嘿，我们知道我们需要转向可再生资源。我们知道电动化即将到来，但我们如何确保我们高效并达到这一点？所以技术在我们可以以多种不同方式利用它来造福人类方面非常有趣。
Yeah, that makes sense. I think there's this similar thing in robotics where you say, you know, once a robot is a necessity, it's called an appliance, right? So it's like your dishwasher. You don't call that a robot anymore. It's now just an appliance. And a Roomba will probably become an appliance. It's just a matter of time. So I've got a five-year-old.
是的，这很有道理。我认为机器人技术中也有类似的事情，你说，你知道，一旦机器人成为必需品，它就被称为家电，对吧？所以就像你的洗碗机。你不再称它为机器人了。它现在只是一台家电。Roomba可能也会成为家电。这只是时间问题。所以我有一个五岁的孩子。
And are you telling me that if he doesn't have to learn how to drive because there will be self-driving cars, we're just going to call them an appliance, not a car? Yeah, or at least we won't be calling it a robot, right? We'll call it just a car, exactly. Yeah, I told my son it's a robot car when we pass by one of those Waymo self-driving cars. And yeah, I think that now it's not even going to make sense to call it a robot car. So someone opens up, and I'm just going to pick something in Waze or one of these apps, and they just a single point destination. They say, I want to go to the grocery store. There's a whole search to find the grocery store. We'll leave that aside. But we get the coordinates of the grocery store. What actually happens that generates that single path for somebody from their house
你是说如果他不需要学习开车，因为会有自动驾驶汽车，我们只会称它们为家电，而不是汽车？是的，或者至少我们不会称它为机器人，对吧？我们会称它为汽车，完全正确。是的，我告诉我的儿子，当我们经过那些Waymo自动驾驶汽车时，那是机器人汽车。是的，我想现在称它为机器人汽车甚至都没有意义了。所以有人打开，我只是要在Waze或这些应用程序中选择一些东西，他们只是一个单点目的地。他们说，我想去杂货店。寻找杂货店有一个完整的搜索过程。我们先不谈这个。但我们得到了杂货店的坐标。到底发生了什么，为某人从他们家生成了那条单一路径
to the grocery store? Like what magic is actually happening to make that show up? You know, it's a really great question that I'd say that I don't necessarily even totally understand the magic myself. I'm sure if I pulled, you know, our co-founder into the conversation, you know, he would have a pretty good answer for you and understand the different data sets that are involved. So I'd say that one's a little bit beyond my, even my own technical know-how, but you know, I do know that it's a lot about just big data, right? And that's probably a term that's thrown around, but what actually happens is just, there's a lot of computing power that happens to make that very simple thing actually come to life. I know that because if we
到杂货店？就像什么魔法在发生，让它显示出来？你知道，这是一个非常好的问题，我会说我自己也不一定完全理解其中的魔法。我相信如果我把我们的联合创始人拉进谈话中，他会给你一个很好的答案，并理解所涉及的不同数据集。所以我说那个超出了我自己的技术知识，但我确实知道这很大程度上是关于大数据，对吧？这可能是一个被到处使用的术语，但实际发生的是，有大量的计算能力使那个非常简单的事情真正实现。我知道这一点，因为如果我们
talk about one point on the map, now let's talk about, you know, just eight points on the map and the actual number of possible variations to build that route starts to become exponential. So if we start building that, the actual number of calculations starts to become mind numbingly high to the point where my simple brain starts to not understand how it is that that all works and how those algorithms are applied. So it's a lot happening behind the scenes that even I don't understand. So maybe that gives hope to others to understand that you don't have to necessarily know, you know, how to build an engine, you know, if you want to drive a car, for example, like to necessarily know, you know, how to build an engine, you know, if you want to drive a car, for example, like driving a car, you really just need to learn,
谈论地图上的一个点，现在让我们谈论地图上的八个点，构建该路线的实际可能变化数量开始呈指数级增长。所以如果我们开始构建它，实际的计算数量开始变得高得令人麻木，以至于我简单的头脑开始不理解它是如何运作的，以及这些算法是如何应用的。所以幕后发生了很多事情，甚至我都不理解。所以也许这给了其他人希望，让他们明白你不一定非要知道如何制造引擎，如果你想开车，例如，像开车，你真的只需要学习，
okay, here's the gas pedal, here's the steering wheel, you know, here's the brake, very important piece. You don't have to know exactly how an engine works. You just, you know, learn to drive the car and you trust it. Yeah. I think it's a really good call out because, you know, you could just, let's say, get the data from, like, there's this thing called open street maps, I think it's a really good call out because you could just, let's say, get the data from, there's this thing called open street maps, I think it's called. And they have all the streets and they'll even tell you, is it a major road? Is it a highway? And so if you have a point, like I have this grocery store at this location, you could find, let's say the nearest street, which that itself could be a problem because maybe the parking lot is not actually the nearest street. But let's put that one aside. So you say you can find the nearest street or at least some place on a street where you need to go.
好的，这是油门，这是方向盘，这是刹车，非常重要的部分。你不必确切地知道引擎是如何工作的。你只需要学习开车，然后信任它。是的。我认为这是一个非常好的呼吁，因为你可以，比如说，从Open Street Maps获取数据，我认为这是一个非常好的呼吁，因为你可以，比如说，获取数据，有一个东西叫Open Street Maps，我想是这样叫的。他们有所有的街道，他们甚至会告诉你，这是一条主干道吗？这是一条高速公路吗？所以如果你有一个点，比如我在这个位置有这个杂货店，你可以找到最近的街道，这本身可能就是一个问题，因为也许停车场实际上不是最近的街道。但让我们把那个放在一边。所以你说你可以找到最近的街道，或者至少是你需要去的街道上的某个地方。
And then you could treat all the little streets as lines and just similar to solving a maze where you try one route and you have to do some backtracking. Maybe you try to go close to the grocery store, but you hit a dead end. And so I have to back up a little bit. This is in the planning. So you're not literally doing this with your car, but in the planning, you have to back up a little bit and try something else. Just like you would erase a line in a maze while you're trying to solve it. And so you could eventually, you know, kind of get that path, but then, you know, it gets really complicated because, you know, in a maze, you're not too concerned about the path itself. Like no one's really holding, like no one's expecting you to find the shortest path through the maze.
然后你可以把所有的小街道当作线条，就像解决迷宫一样，你尝试一条路线，你必须进行一些回溯。也许你试图靠近杂货店，但你遇到了死胡同。所以我必须后退一点。这是在规划中。所以你不是真的用你的车做这个，但在规划中，你必须后退一点并尝试其他东西。就像你在解决迷宫时擦掉一条线一样。所以你最终可以得到那条路径，但它变得非常复杂，因为在迷宫中，你不太关心路径本身。没有人期望你找到穿过迷宫的最短路径。
And the maze also is just kind of spatial. So every direction is just going as fast as your pencil's moving. But in the real world, you have different speed limits. Some roads have traffic lights, some don't. I know for me, Google Maps always seems to take me on the highway. And maybe it is faster, but it is kind of a pain. Just get on the highway for two stops when I could have just taken a straight line. And so that's one where it's faster, but it is kind of a pain. Just get on the highway for two stops when I could have just taken a straight line, you know? And so that's one where it's like, then it's not even about the fastest time. It's about the best experience for the driver. Yeah. I mean, if you think about Waze, one of their unique advantages was being able to build that data set. And that
而且迷宫也只是空间上的。所以每个方向都像你的铅笔移动得一样快。但在现实世界中，你有不同的限速。有些路有红绿灯，有些没有。我知道对我来说，谷歌地图似乎总是带我走高速公路。也许它确实更快，但确实有点麻烦。为了两个出口就上高速公路，而我本可以直接走直线。所以这就是那种情况，它更快，但确实有点麻烦。为了两个出口就上高速公路，而我本可以直接走直线。所以这就是那种情况，它甚至不是关于最快的时间。它是关于司机的最佳体验。是的。我的意思是，如果你想到Waze，他们独特的优势之一是能够构建那个数据集。而那个
data set was user generated feedback. So that user generated data where someone could go into a really easy, clean interface that was easy to use and start to report things. And so, you know, I still use Waze myself. Am I allowed to say that working at Route for me? Actually, yeah, we could interject a little bit. What is Route4Me? Does Route4Me compliment something like wait, like do you do? It does. Okay, got it. You know, we don't consider ourselves really a navigation app necessarily. You know, we're more before on route planning for more complex, high volume or high number of stops with advanced constraints. I mean, you mentioned a few of them,
数据集是用户生成的反馈。所以那个用户生成的数据，有人可以进入一个非常简单、干净、易于使用的界面并开始报告事情。所以，我仍然自己使用Waze。我在Route4Me工作，我能说这个吗？其实，是的，我们可以插话一点。什么是Route4Me？Route4Me是补充像Waze这样的东西吗？它确实。好的，明白了。我们不认为自己是导航应用程序。我们更多是在处理更复杂、高容量或高停靠点数量且有高级约束的路线规划。我的意思是，你提到了其中的几个，
you know, there's one way streets, there's stoplights, there's weather, there's time, you know, there's all kinds of different constraints. So planning routes can get really complex really quickly. And, you know, navigating routes, once you have the sequence, you know, navigating is wonderful to use something if you're able to use something like Waze and that user generated feedback. I love using those navigation applications. And, you know, maybe it tells me there's police ahead or construction or tells me to take, you know, a path that in real time is generating that data from other users who unfortunately maybe got stuck in a little traffic, but are kind of helping me, you know, following behind to make sure that I don't make that traffic worse. So it's a wonderful thing. You talk about technology kind of solving problems, you know, as they're happening. Yeah. Yeah. It makes sense. Yeah. So I think, yeah. And I mean, one thing that's always struck me is how expansive that space is, right? I mean, think about when you have Google Maps on your dashboard and you're driving someplace,
有单行道，有红绿灯，有天气，有时间，有各种各样的不同约束。所以规划路线很快就会变得非常复杂。而且，导航路线，一旦你有了顺序，导航使用像Waze这样的东西是非常棒的，如果你能使用像Waze那样的用户生成反馈的话。我喜欢使用那些导航应用程序。而且，也许它告诉我前面有警察或施工，或者告诉我走一条在实时中从其他用户那里生成数据的路径，那些用户不幸可能被困在一点交通中，但他们正在帮助我，确保我不会让交通变得更糟。所以这是一件美妙的事情。你谈到技术解决问题，当它们发生时。是的。是的。有道理。是的。所以我想，是的。而且我的意思是，一直让我印象深刻的一件事是那个空间是多么广阔，对吧？我的意思是，想想当你的仪表盘上有谷歌地图，你开车去某个地方时，
all those roads that you see on that map and they're all passing by you at 50 miles an hour, maybe more than that if you're on the highway, you know, and all of those are, you know, directions that you at least somewhat have to consider when you're figuring out this path. I mean, there's probably a lot of rules that you can follow that help this a lot, like get to the highway as quickly as possible or something like that. But even then, it's just the amount of
你在那张地图上看到的所有那些道路，它们都以每小时50英里的速度从你身边经过，如果你在高速公路上，可能更快，所有这些都是你在计算这条路径时至少要考虑的指示。我的意思是，可能有很多规则你可以遵循，这很有帮助，比如尽快到达高速公路之类的。但即便如此，计算量
computation, you know, to fetch all of these paths must be just absolutely extraordinary. I mean, it's mind blowing. It is. And, you know, it's interesting because you're like skimming the surface in a way to like, to kind of think about it from this perspective is we're just talking about like ways a little bit, like there are many, many different rules of the road for what are commercial vehicle restrictions. So if you have, you know, you probably seen these on the road, even through the highway, you know, if you said, okay, no, no trucks, you know, you've probably seen these on the road, even through the highway, you know, if you said, okay, no, no trucks, you know, through this certain highway or through a certain town. And that's usually due to a weight restriction, potentially a hazardous material restriction.
获取所有这些路径的计算量一定是非常惊人的。我的意思是，这令人难以置信。确实。而且，这很有趣，因为你就像在表面上掠过，从这个角度去思考，我们只是在谈论Waze，就像有很多很多不同的道路规则，关于什么是商用车辆限制。所以如果你有，你可能在路上看到过这些，甚至在高速公路上，如果你说，好的，没有卡车，你可能在路上看到过这些，甚至在高速公路上，如果你说，好的，没有卡车，通过这条特定的高速公路或通过某个城镇。这通常是由于重量限制，潜在的危险材料限制。
So certain vehicles, depending on their, you know, cargo or capacity or vehicle constraints actually can't go on certain roads and they can't use navigation applications like Waze or Google Maps because they might send them down the wrong road. And, you know, it's, you know, maybe not the worst thing for many things. If you're a little overweight, it's not good for the road, not good for the infrastructure. At the same time, you know, this happens all the time that a vehicle runs into the bottom of a bridge. So low bridges are a major concern. So imagine, imagine you're a business owner and, you know, you've planned this route and your driver, you get a call and next thing you know, like half of,
所以某些车辆，根据它们的货物、容量或车辆限制，实际上不能走某些道路，它们不能使用像Waze或谷歌地图这样的导航应用程序，因为它们可能会把它们送到错误的道路上。而且，这可能不是最糟糕的事情。如果你有点超重，这对道路不好，对基础设施不好。同时，这种情况一直发生，车辆撞到桥底。所以低矮的桥梁是一个主要问题。所以想象一下，想象你是一个企业主，你规划了这条路线，你的司机，你接到一个电话，然后你知道，卡车的一半
you know, the truck has been kind of like a can opener and, you know, that's not a fun call, nothing fun to deal with. And insurance goes up, you know, costs go up, you know, customers are definitely not happy. So there's so many things to take into account, even from that commercial, it's kind of solving the problem or trying to solve what is a P versus NP problem, which if anyone solves that, I mean, it's like, if you can solve P versus NP, you can cure cancer. Apparently, again, a lot of this going over my head, but like, you know, we're still trying to deal with the problems we have with whatever data sets and solutions that we actually can access. So it's interesting that more and more data sets are being built, you know, for example, with Waze.
就像一个开罐器，那不是一个有趣的电话，也不是什么好处理的事情。保险费上涨，成本上涨，客户肯定不高兴。所以有太多的事情要考虑，即使从商业角度来看，它是在解决问题，或者试图解决一个P对NP问题，如果有人解决了这个问题，我的意思是，如果你能解决P对NP，你就能治愈癌症。显然，这又超出了我的理解范围，但我们仍在尝试用我们能访问的任何数据集和解决方案来处理我们面临的问题。所以有趣的是，越来越多的数据集正在被构建，例如，使用Waze。
Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense. Yeah, actually, it's a really good call out. I think there's a lot of these sort of commentorial problems. A lot of people, you know, they would see, say, protein folding for, you know, studying cancer treatment and figuring out the way to get to Starbucks as like totally different problems. But from a mathematical standpoint, you can actually find a homomorphism. You can find a way to morph one into the other. The example I give a lot of people is Sudoku. So, you know, you look at Sudoku, which is just for people who don't know, it's this game where you have a nine by nine grid of squares and then the squares are also grouped.
是的，是的，完全有道理。是的，实际上，这是一个非常好的呼吁。我认为有很多这种组合问题。很多人，他们会看到，比如说蛋白质折叠用于研究癌症治疗，和找出到达星巴克的路径，是完全不同的问题。但从数学角度来看，你实际上可以找到一个同态。你可以找到一种将一个变形为另一个的方法。我给很多人举的例子是数独。所以，你看看数独，对于不知道的人来说，这是一个游戏，你有一个9x9的方格网，然后方格也被分组。
So you also have this sort of three by three grid of groups, you know, all on the same grid. And your goal is to place the numbers one through nine, you know, multiple times on this, I guess, nine times on this grid, so that every row only has one of each number. And every column only has one of each number. And every cell, every group only has one of each number. Now, like if you had a blank Sudoku, that would be easy. But usually, then the Sudoku has some numbers already filled in. So every time you go to one, it's a little bit different. And that seems like a pretty abstract problem if you wanted to solve it using computers. But actually, it's very similar to another problem, which is called graph coloring. And so graph
所以你也有这种3x3的组网格，都在同一个网格上。你的目标是放置数字1到9，在这个网格上多次，我想是9次，这样每一行只有一个每个数字。每一列只有一个每个数字。每一个单元格，每一个组只有一个每个数字。现在，如果你有一个空白的数独，那很容易。但通常，数独已经填入了一些数字。所以每次你去玩一个，它都有点不同。如果你想用计算机解决它，这似乎是一个相当抽象的问题。但实际上，它非常类似于另一个问题，叫做图着色。所以图
coloring is a problem where you have a graph. Let's say this graph is representing a map. You have a node for every intersection on the map and you have an edge for every street that exists on the map. And graph coloring says, I want to color all these intersections so that two intersections that have a street between them don't get the same color.
着色是一个问题，你有一个图。假设这个图代表一张地图。地图上的每个交叉口都有一个节点，地图上存在的每条街道都有一个边。图着色说，我想给所有这些交叉口着色，这样两个之间有街道的交叉口就不会得到相同的颜色。
So if I pick green for this intersection, then all the ones at that intersection can reach immediately have to be other colors besides green. And it turns out you can actually think of Sudoku as a graph where every one of those cells is an intersection and there's a road connecting that cell to all its neighbors. And if you do that, then it just becomes a graph calling problem. So there's a road connecting that cell to all its neighbors. And if you do that, then it just becomes a graph calling problem. And so that's a way you can morph something that seems pretty abstract into something that has like a bunch of solutions you can just download off the internet. And it turns out almost all of these problems, whether it's route planning, protein folding, most puzzles you see in the real world
所以如果我为这个交叉口选择绿色，那么那个交叉口可以立即到达的所有交叉口都必须是绿色以外的其他颜色。事实证明，你实际上可以把数独看作一个图，其中每一个单元格都是一个交叉口，有一条路连接那个单元格和它所有的邻居。如果你这样做，那么它就变成了一个图着色问题。所以有一条路连接那个单元格和它所有的邻居。如果你这样做，那么它就变成了一个图着色问题。所以这是一种你可以将看起来相当抽象的东西变形为具有一堆你可以直接从互联网上下载的解决方案的东西的方法。事实证明，几乎所有这些问题，无论是路线规划、蛋白质折叠，你在现实世界中看到的大多数谜题
and online, almost all of them can be reduced down to the same problem, which we call satisfiability. And it turns out solving any of those is really, really hard. So what you have to do is make a lot of really good guesses. And so, for example, you know, this idea of let's get on the highway as quickly as possible and then let's take the highway and you're 80 miles away from your destination, you don't really have to worry about, should I take this exit or not? Because you're clearly not there yet, unless the exit is another highway. And so using a lot of these tricks, you can take these problems that otherwise you can't really solve and you can make them much more practical. The thing that's really interesting about protein folding is, you know, unlike the highway where you have a lot of common sense reasoning, you don't really have a lot of common sense reasoning about proteins.
和在线，几乎所有这些都可以简化为同一个问题，我们称之为可满足性。事实证明，解决其中任何一个都非常非常困难。所以你必须做出很多非常好的猜测。所以，例如，这个想法是尽快上高速公路，然后走高速公路，你离目的地还有80英里，你真的不必担心，我应该走这个出口还是不走？因为你显然还没到那里，除非出口是另一条高速公路。所以使用很多这些技巧，你可以解决这些否则你无法真正解决的问题，你可以使它们变得更加实用。关于蛋白质折叠，真正有趣的事情是，不像高速公路，你有大量的常识推理，你对蛋白质没有太多的常识推理。
And so the thing that was amazing about the protein folding was the work from DeepMind, where they actually just, again, as you said earlier, used a ton of data to build up kind of machine common sense reasoning, and then use that reasoning that the machine has developed from just looking at a lot of proteins being folded, use that information to discover kind of new protein combinations that were really effective. It's interesting you say that too. What's interesting to me is relating it back to routing is, you know, we can take, for example, let's take a thousand stops and just imagine it's like your job to go route 10 drivers or how many drivers do you actually really need to go visit
所以关于蛋白质折叠令人惊奇的事情是DeepMind的工作，他们实际上只是，正如你之前所说，使用了大量的数据来建立某种机器常识推理，然后使用机器从观察大量蛋白质折叠中发展出来的推理，利用这些信息来发现某种非常有效的新的蛋白质组合。你这么说也很有趣。对我来说有趣的是将其与路线规划联系起来，我们可以采取，例如，让我们采取一千个停靠点，想象一下你的工作是为10个司机规划路线，或者你实际上真的需要去访问多少个司机
these 1000 stops? And we see this all the time. And so, you know, with a program like route for me to kind of with these set of rules, hooking these data sets, we can go solve that problem the best that we can. And time is a really critical component here. You know, could we solve the problem better with more time? The answer is yes. And what I often see is when we give you a result to say, okay, I took your thousand stops and you've got a number of advanced constraints. You've got time windows at them. Maybe you've got priorities.
这1000个停靠点？我们经常看到这种情况。所以，你知道，有了像Route4Me这样的程序，加上这些规则和数据集的对接，我们就能尽可能好地解决这个问题。时间在这里是一个非常关键的因素。你知道，如果我们有更多的时间，我们能把问题解决得更好吗？答案是肯定的。我经常看到的是，当我们给你一个结果，说“好的，我处理了你的1000个停靠点，你有一系列高级约束条件。你有时间窗口。也许你还有优先级。”
You've got different weights and all kinds of different other problems with it. I took a thousand stops and within less than 60 seconds, here's the eight vehicles or eight routes that you need, and they're all sequenced in the right order. And so it's really easy as I think a human being to kind of spot the flaws. And to that point, to your point of like, well, should I take the highway or, you know, why is it always sending me the highway or is there a better route? And the answer is yes, you could actually beat, you know, the system, right? Like you could refine it, but I guarantee there's not a human being in the world that could take a thousand stops and route them,
你有不同的权重以及各种各样其他的问题。我处理了1000个停靠点，在不到60秒的时间内，这就是你需要的那8辆车或8条路线，而且它们都按正确的顺序排列好了。所以，作为人类，我认为发现其中的缺陷真的很容易。说到这一点，就像你说的，“好吧，我应该走高速公路吗？或者，为什么它总是让我走高速公路？有没有更好的路线？”答案是肯定的，你确实可以胜过系统，对吧？你可以优化它，但我敢保证，世界上没有一个人能处理1000个停靠点并为它们规划路线，
you know, to the fewest number of vehicles in 60 seconds. I would like to meet that person if possible. So it's funny how as human beings, like we spot these flaws and say, well, you gave me out eight routes, but I could have made this stop a little bit different, you know? So it's about time to actually solve the problems too, which is really critically important, especially in a business scenario where you actually have to get out the door. And like I mentioned earlier, I have a five-year-old, I got to get them dressed and ready to get out the door. And if there was a software solution or some solution that could help me get them dressed faster, I would absolutely engage with that appliance, so to speak.
你知道，在60秒内用最少的车辆完成。如果可能的话，我想见见那个人。所以很有趣，作为人类，我们发现这些缺陷并说：“好吧，你给了我8条路线，但我本可以让这个停靠点稍微不同一点，你知道吗？”所以，实际上解决问题也需要时间，这在商业场景中非常关键，因为你必须得出门。就像我之前提到的，我有一个五岁的孩子，我得帮他们穿好衣服，准备出门。如果有一个软件解决方案或某种方案能帮我让他们更快穿好衣服，我绝对会使用那个工具，可以这么说。
Yeah, that's right. Yeah, it's a really good call out. So yeah, so we talked about doing a single route. Now imagine, you know, just getting from point A to point B is really hard, right? I mean, it's people look at it as magic. We tried to unpack it, but you know, there's so much depth there. I mean, we barely scratched the surface. It's hard. Right now, imagine you actually don't want just to get from point A to point B. You're at point A, and maybe there's a thousand people who are at point A. Point A is some distribution facility. And then as you said, there's a thousand other points. And these people have to cover all those thousand points in a day. I mean, imagine Amazon. So Amazon has this massive distribution center and, uh, you know, they have a whole list of
是的，没错。这是一个非常好的切入点。所以，我们谈到了规划单条路线。现在想象一下，你知道，仅仅是从A点到B点就非常困难，对吧？人们把它看作是魔法。我们试图拆解它，但你知道，这里面有太多的深度。我的意思是，我们只是触及了皮毛。这很难。现在，想象一下你实际上不仅仅是想从A点到B点。你在A点，也许有1000个人也在A点。A点是一个配送中心。然后正如你所说，还有1000个其他点。这些人必须在一天内覆盖所有这1000个点。想象一下亚马逊。所以亚马逊有一个巨大的配送中心，而且，你知道，他们有一长串
people who want packages delivered, you know, on this day and they have an army of trucks. And so they have to figure out how do we get all these packages to all these people, you know, before, before the clock runs out for, I think it's 10 PM or something is when they say your package will be delivered by, right? So that, I mean, that is, and even just getting one of those routes or one of those paths, like even just saying, take this package from Amazon to this person's house, that is really hard. And the problem that Parker just described is just needs that as like one atomic piece of it. I guess all of this is just a route planning is really, really hard. It's extremely difficult. But it's so necessary. And it's interesting
想要在这一天收到包裹的人，他们有一支卡车大军。所以他们必须弄清楚我们如何把所有这些包裹送到所有人手中，你知道，在时间耗尽之前，我想是晚上10点左右，他们说你的包裹会在那个时间之前送达，对吧？所以，我的意思是，这确实是，即使只是得到其中一条路线或其中一条路径，比如仅仅是说，把这个包裹从亚马逊送到这个人的家里，这真的很难。而帕克刚才描述的问题只是其中的一个原子部分。我想所有这些都只是路线规划，真的非常非常难。这极其困难。但这是非常有必要的。而且很有趣，
because you mentioned that like one piece, even before you can get to route planning is, and you kind of mentioned it earlier, is geocoding. Just the process of geocoding and saying, okay, well, when you type in, you know, 123 Main Street, you know, that could mean anywhere in the world. So giving it and filtering that data down a little bit further and getting a really confident idea of where we're going is critical. And because if you, in that same scenario, if you're a delivery driver and you have 50 stops, a hundred stops, 200 stops to go to in a day, if you don't geocode to the right address, it kind of reminds me of Michael Scott, you know, and Dwight running into the lake with the GPS system a little bit. It really throws you off course. And it's a huge time investment, really a time waster, not just to mention the carbon emissions of waste, but if you don't go to the right person, now you have to figure out, okay, I didn't go to the right address. What is
因为你提到那一点，甚至在进行路线规划之前，你之前也提到了，就是地理编码。仅仅是地理编码的过程，说“好的，当你输入123主街时，那可能意味着世界上的任何地方。”所以，提供它并进一步过滤这些数据，并对我们要去的地方有一个非常确定的概念是至关重要的。因为如果你在同样的情况下，如果你是一名送货司机，一天有50个、100个、200个停靠点，如果你没有对正确的地址进行地理编码，这让我想起了迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）和德怀特（Dwight）带着GPS系统冲进湖里的情景。它真的会让你偏离航线。这是一个巨大的时间投入，真的是浪费时间，更不用说浪费造成的碳排放了，但如果你没有去对人那里，现在你必须弄清楚，“好的，我没有去正确的地址。什么是
the right address? Who can help me figure that out? Do I have to call the customer? And so that geocoding process is really, really critical. And that happens before you can plan the route. So you mentioned something earlier is, well, how do you geocode? Do you geocode based on the curbside latitude, longitude coordinates? Do you geocode based on the rooftop? And how do you measure that rooftop? So there's so much that goes into just, you know, geocoding and finding the actual locations before saying, okay, now let's plan the route. So it's really, really fascinating to go through that process. And what's important, you know, at least from our perspective at Route4Me is just to make that really easy, you know, and make it magic. You know, again, you don't have to know how the car works, you know, but,
正确的地址？谁能帮我弄清楚？我必须给客户打电话吗？”所以那个地理编码过程真的非常非常关键。这发生在你可以规划路线之前。所以你之前提到了一些事情，就是“好吧，你怎么进行地理编码？你是根据路边的经纬度坐标进行地理编码吗？你是根据屋顶进行地理编码吗？你如何测量那个屋顶？”所以，在说“好的，现在让我们规划路线”之前，仅仅是地理编码和找到实际位置就涉及很多东西。所以经历这个过程真的非常非常迷人。重要的是，你知道，至少从我们Route4Me的角度来看，就是让它变得非常简单，你知道，让它变得像魔法一样。你知道，再说一次，你不必知道汽车是如何工作的，你知道，但是，
you know, you do have to drive it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I think that we should spend a little bit of time talking about crowdsourcing. So as we talked about in the beginning, you know, finding a path from A to B without any sort of, let's say, hacks or cheats or whatever you want to call it, assumptions, let's say, is not tractable, right? Like if you really want to consider, maybe I need to, so right now I'm in Texas, you know, maybe to get to the grocery store, maybe I need to go to Florida and come back. I mean, maybe, but you know, we know that from common sense that that's not true, but you know, in the complete abstract, like you would need to search everything. So then you can say, well, let's let's kind of make some assumptions.
你知道，你确实必须驾驶它。是的，这完全说得通。我认为我们应该花点时间谈谈众包。所以正如我们在开头谈到的，你知道，在没有任何所谓的黑客手段或作弊，或者你想怎么称呼它，假设，在没有任何假设的情况下找到从A到B的路径，是不可行的，对吧？比如，如果你真的想考虑，也许我需要，所以现在我在德克萨斯州，你知道，也许要去杂货店，也许我需要去佛罗里达再回来。我的意思是，也许，但你知道，我们凭常识知道那是不对的，但你知道，在完全抽象的情况下，你需要搜索所有东西。所以你可以说，“好吧，让我们做一些假设。”
Now, some of the assumptions are obvious. So, for example, the speed limit is not going to be the speed of light. And so going to Florida and coming back is almost for sure not the right answer. And so, you know, you can make assumptions about just how fast can you possibly get from point A to point B and use that to say, I'm done looking, you know, I've got this route. And, you know, when I look at the ways I could change it, all of them just make it mathematically impossible to get there, you know, let's say significantly quicker. So then, but then some of the assumptions become things that you have to learn. So, for example, maybe your system that does the geocoding. It actually just happened to me.
现在，有些假设是显而易见的。例如，速度限制不会是光速。所以去佛罗里达再回来几乎肯定不是正确的答案。所以，你知道，你可以对从A点到B点可能有多快做出假设，并用它来说，“我不再寻找了，你知道，我已经有了这条路线。”而且，你知道，当我查看我可以改变它的方式时，所有这些方式在数学上都使得不可能到达那里，你知道，比方说显著更快。所以，但随后一些假设变成了你必须学习的东西。例如，也许你的进行地理编码的系统。这实际上就发生在我身上。
My wife and I do a lot of hiking. My family, we do a lot of hiking. And sometimes we'll put in a name of a hiking trail or a hiking park. And I remember one time specifically, we put in this place called The Dish, which is a hiking trail with a lot of satellite dishes that's on the Stanford campus. And so we put in The Dish and Google Maps actually took us to the border of the highway and The Dish. So we're going, you know, 70 miles an hour on the highway and map says, you know, you're here done. And so I did my job. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Got me.
我和我妻子经常徒步旅行。我的家人，我们经常徒步旅行。有时我们会输入一个徒步小径或徒步公园的名字。我记得有一次特别深刻，我们输入了一个叫“The Dish”的地方，那是一条有很多卫星天线的徒步小径，位于斯坦福大学校园内。所以我们输入了“The Dish”，谷歌地图实际上把我们带到了高速公路的边缘和“The Dish”的交界处。所以我们当时正以每小时70英里的速度在高速公路上行驶，地图说，“你知道，你到了，结束了。”所以我完成了我的工作。谢谢。是的。谢谢。抓到我了。
I can see the dish. I can actually see the dishes very clearly, but no, we wanted, right. It was a way to park so that we could walk on the trail. And so that's an example where, you know, what we did was what anyone would do. We got off the highway, we found the way to get to the parking lot or to the street rather, and we parked there. And so what maps can do, and I'm sure what they are doing is, you know, they're looking at that. So every time, you know, you purposely, or every time you don't go to the destination that maps told you to go to, but you actually go somewhere else, you know, they're tracking that if they see, you know, 60, 70% of the people who we sent to the dish actually parked over here, then that they can use that signal later on to fix, you know, their geo coding
我能看到那个天线，我实际上能非常清楚地看到那些天线，但不是，我们想要的是，对吧。那是一个停车的地方，这样我们就可以在小径上行走。所以这是一个例子，你知道，我们所做的是任何人都会做的事情。我们下了高速公路，找到了去停车场或街道的路，然后我们停在那里。所以地图能做的，而且我相信他们正在做的，是，你知道，他们正在观察这一点。所以每次，你知道，你故意，或者每次你没有去地图告诉你要去的目的地，但你实际上去了别的地方，你知道，他们正在追踪这一点。如果他们看到，你知道，60%到70%我们发送到“The Dish”的人实际上停在了这里，那么他们以后就可以利用这个信号来修复，你知道，他们的地理编码
and their other systems. Yeah. It's user generated feedback, right? And it's something you see. And it's so funny that you mentioned that because we tend to have a blind faith or I do, maybe some others don't, but we have a blind faith in technology and in those data sets already being there. And I think it's easy to make that assumption that they are, and they're still being built. You know, Google is still building things. I think, you know, anyone who's, you know, and they, the roads change. So you'll see, you know, the maps change, you'll see satellite images change, things are constantly in flux. And what's fascinating from that perspective, from a route optimization perspective is you might find many businesses say, well, I'm okay,
以及他们的其他系统。是的。这是用户生成的反馈，对吧？这是你看到的东西。你提到这一点真是太有趣了，因为我们往往有一种盲目的信仰，或者我有，也许其他人没有，但我们对技术以及那些已经存在的数据集有一种盲目的信仰。我认为做出它们已经存在的假设很容易，而且它们仍在构建中。你知道，谷歌仍在构建东西。我想，你知道，任何，你知道，而且他们，道路会改变。所以你会看到，你知道，地图会改变，你会看到卫星图像会改变，事物在不断变化。从那个角度来看，从路线优化的角度来看，令人着迷的是，你可能会发现许多企业说，“好吧，我没问题，
my routes don't really change. And what we find is that they do. There are so many variables at play that it will change. And those data sets are continually being updated. And so, you know, you're contributing every so often when you take the wrong path, it sounds like. So that's, you know, pushing humankind a little bit further, which is a good thing. So the next person hopefully won't get lost to seeing the dishes. Yeah, yeah, right. Yeah. And so I think you're harnessing all of that data. And this is one thing we've mentioned on the show several times, but it's a good point to just really drive it home is how important statistics is. And it's one of those areas that it's really interesting. Statistics is, there was a time actually when machine learning was in the statistics department.
我的路线并没有真正改变。”而我们发现它们确实会改变。有太多的变量在起作用，它会改变。这些数据集在不断更新。所以，你知道，听起来当你走错路时，你每隔一段时间就会做出贡献。所以，你知道，这把人类稍微向前推进了一点，这是一件好事。所以下一个人希望不会因为看天线而迷路。是的，是的，没错。是的。所以我认为你正在利用所有这些数据。这是我们在节目中提到过几次的一件事，但这是一个很好的点，可以真正深入人心，那就是统计学有多么重要。这是非常有趣的领域之一。统计学是，实际上曾经有一段时间机器学习是在统计学系里的。
And at that time, machine learning didn't actually, didn't get a lot of recognition. And so the people who are studying AI, and so I'm thinking about maybe the 60s or 70 protein folding. And I think that these sort of numerical methods like neural networks could be used to solve those problems. Those people were like relegated off to the statistics department and it was difficult for them to get funding. And it's always, there's always this joke that like the statistics department is kind of like a second-class citizen to the math department. But it's actually, you know, I hope that, you know, when I was going to college, it was a different department. I really think we need to have some sort of, you know, unification here because what I see is a lot of people graduating from college
在那个时候，机器学习实际上并没有得到太多的认可。所以那些研究人工智能的人，所以我想到的是也许60年代或70年代的蛋白质折叠。而且我认为这些数值方法，比如神经网络，可以用来解决这些问题。那些人被降级到了统计学系，他们很难获得资金。而且总是，总是有这样一个笑话，说统计学系有点像数学系的二等公民。但实际上，你知道，我希望，你知道，当我上大学时，它是不同的系。我真的认为我们需要在这里进行某种统一，因为我看到很多大学毕业生
with a ton of engineering knowledge, but missing a lot of the core statistics knowledge. And then when you have a problem like this, where it is stochastic by nature, right? Like, you know, in our case, we saw the dish, we needed to park there. And so we left Google Maps on and we found the parking spot. But there's a lot of people who will just shut the Google Maps off. Maybe they'll turn the app off completely so the data isn't collected afterwards. There might be some people who even park on the highway and I don't know, maybe they, I don't know what they do after that. Right. But the point is there's uncertainty and with everything, it's all fuzzy and uncertain. And having that statistics background will allow you to sort of separate the signal from the noise to where you can automatically without a person in the loop,
拥有大量的工程知识，但缺少很多核心的统计学知识。然后当你遇到像这样的问题时，它本质上是随机的，对吧？比如，你知道，在我们的例子中，我们看到了天线，我们需要在那里停车。所以我们让谷歌地图开着，我们找到了停车位。但有很多人会直接关掉谷歌地图。也许他们会完全关掉应用程序，这样数据就不会被收集。可能有些人甚至停在高速公路上，我不知道，也许他们，我不知道他们之后做了什么。对吧。但重点是存在不确定性，一切都是模糊和不确定的。拥有统计学背景将允许你以某种方式将信号从噪声中分离出来，这样你就可以自动地，无需人在循环中，
you can say, you know, like enough people have made this class of mistakes. You could build sort of a space around that mistake and see a lot of density there and automatically correct it. And so actually, you know, one kind of question along these lines is to what degree is this automated? And to what degree do you have, you know, an army of people an army of people fixing things all over the country or all over the world? So I think what's important about Route for me is we're similar in the sense that we're hooking into those data sets. So we're hooking into data sets from many of the vendors that you mentioned. And we also build our own proprietary data sets. And so much of it's automated in terms of what we do from a route planning perspective, a route optimization perspective. And we've just tried
你可以说，“你知道，足够多的人犯了这类错误。”你可以围绕那个错误建立某种空间，并在那里看到很多密度，并自动纠正它。所以实际上，你知道，沿着这些思路的一个问题是，这在多大程度上是自动化的？在多大程度上你有一支人马，一支在全国或全世界各地修复东西的人马？所以我认为关于Route4Me重要的一点是，我们是相似的，因为我们正在接入那些数据集。所以我们正在接入你提到的许多供应商的数据集。而且我们也构建我们自己的专有数据集。所以从路线规划的角度，路线优化的角度来看，我们所做的大部分是自动化的。而且我们只是尝试
to make it simpler and easier for users because imagine, you know, if you were going to that same hike and you actually had to go research out of a book and learn how to program, you know, some code into, you know, your computer in order to kind of get the result, you probably wouldn't go do it. You just probably go find the place and little trial and error, maybe ask some people, stop at a gas station. So from the question of like, most of it's automated, what we do, and we're just looking into vendors, you know, solving, you know, with our proprietary algorithm, our routing engine, so to speak, and let people use that engine to plan their routes and optimize, you know, you know, reminds me of an old telephone operator being like, oh, someone just put an input in with a thousand stops. We got to go figure it out for them. Yeah, that's right.
让用户变得更简单、更容易，因为想象一下，你知道，如果你要去那次同样的徒步旅行，而你实际上必须去研究一本书，并学习如何将一些代码编程到你的电脑里，以便得到结果，你可能不会去那样做。你可能只会去找到那个地方，稍微试错一下，也许问问别人，在加油站停一下。所以从“大部分是自动化的”这个问题来看，我们所做的，我们只是在查看供应商，你知道，用我们的专有算法，我们的路由引擎，可以这么说，解决问题，并让人们使用那个引擎来规划他们的路线并进行优化，你知道，让我想起了一个老电话接线员，就像，“哦，有人刚刚输入了1000个停靠点。我们得去为他们弄清楚。”是的，没错。
Impossible. So most of it's automated to a point. At the same time, there still needs to be an operator. There's still someone today, for example, in businesses that they don't often have, or at least from my experience, they don't often have a background in computer programming, logistics, or anything like that. They started in the company and they ended up in that role because maybe they had a natural tendency to it. I sort of lovingly refer to the people in those roles as having that Russell Crowe, a beautiful mind brain where numbers float across the screen and their brain just naturally kind of
不可能。所以大部分是自动化的，到了一定程度。与此同时，仍然需要一个操作员。今天仍然有人，例如，在企业中，他们通常没有，或者至少根据我的经验，他们通常没有计算机编程、物流或类似方面的背景。他们从公司开始，最终担任那个角色，因为也许他们对此有天然的倾向。我亲切地称那些角色中的人为拥有那种罗素·克劳（Russell Crowe）《美丽心灵》的大脑，数字在屏幕上浮动，他们的大脑自然而然地
are good at that. And so they fell into it. And when they come across a solution like Ralph for me, suddenly they just, you know, made their lives so much easier and better. And that's, you know, because they're going to operate it. They're just going to operate with more efficiency. They're going to be able to do more with a lot less and do it a lot faster too. You know, what might take them four hours to do, they can now do in 20 minutes or less, sometimes less. We've seen it even like less than five minutes. And so now they can do other things that they were supposed to be doing anyways and, you know, actually get things done, increase efficiencies. So I'd say most of it's automated, but there still has to be an operator, which is its own data set, very unique to the organization or individual that actually is going to go and perform the action. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah. I mean,
擅长那个。所以他们陷入了那个角色。当他们遇到像Route4Me这样的解决方案时，突然间他们就，你知道，让他们的生活变得如此简单和美好。而且那是，你知道，因为他们将操作它。他们只是将以更高的效率操作。他们将能够用少得多的东西做更多的事情，而且做得更快。你知道，可能需要他们四个小时做的事情，他们现在可以在20分钟或更短的时间内完成，有时更短。我们甚至看到过不到五分钟。所以现在他们可以做他们本来应该做的其他事情，你知道，实际上完成事情，提高效率。所以我说大部分是自动化的，但仍然必须有一个操作员，这是它自己的数据集，对实际将要去执行该动作的组织或个人非常独特。是的。是的。这说得通。是的。我的意思是，
one really fascinating area and it's a brand new area. Well, nothing is brand new, right? Everything is incremental, but it's an area I think that will grow tremendously is this idea of inverse decision making, right? So for example, let's say you just had a large data set of people who drove routes. Maybe they use Google Maps, maybe they were just using their own memory, right? But you just had a large data set of routes and you don't necessarily know where they came from. You just know that people were driving these routes. Then you could ask yourself, okay, let's assume that these people, again, in aggregate, were doing the right thing. Well, then what is the algorithm that can match that? So in other words, what is the algorithm that would do
一个非常迷人的领域，这是一个全新的领域。好吧，没有什么东西是全新的，对吧？一切都是渐进的，但我认为这是一个会巨大增长的领域，就是这种逆向决策的想法，对吧？所以例如，假设你刚刚拥有一个驾驶路线的人的大型数据集。也许他们使用谷歌地图，也许他们只是使用他们自己的记忆，对吧？但你只是拥有一个大型的路线数据集，你并不一定知道它们来自哪里。你只知道人们在驾驶这些路线。那么你可以问自己，“好的，让我们假设这些人，再说一次，在总体上，是在做正确的事情。”那么，什么算法可以匹配它呢？换句话说，什么算法会做
something the same way that these people are doing it? And so, you know, you can clone their behavior. So in other words, let's say everyone who gets to the stop sign and wants to go to the grocery store makes a left. And so you can memorize that. You can say, yeah, I have this algorithm. And when it gets to the stop sign to go to the grocery store, it makes a left. What's even more interesting is saying like, okay, I want to trade off, you know, the headache of driving to the highway versus going just straight to the grocery store, but hitting a bunch of stoplights. You know, I have a threshold, imagine like a little knob. And when you turn it to the right, you just send people to the highway, you know, no matter what.
一些事情，方式与这些人做的方式相同？所以，你知道，你可以克隆他们的行为。换句话说，假设每个到达停车标志并想去杂货店的人都会左转。所以你可以记住这一点。你可以说，“是的，我有这个算法。当它到达停车标志去杂货店时，它会左转。”更令人感兴趣的是说，“好的，我想权衡，你知道，开车去高速公路的头痛与直接去杂货店，但遇到一堆红绿灯。”你知道，我有一个阈值，想象像一个小旋钮。当你把它向右转时，你只是把人们送到高速公路，你知道，无论如何。
If you turn it to the left, then you avoid the highway. It's like checking the avoid highways button on Waze or Maps. And you just send the person as much of a straight line as you can. I think MapQuest used to call this the shortest route versus the fastest route. But imagine you had this little knob
如果你把它向左转，那么你就避开高速公路。这就像在Waze或地图上勾选“避开高速公路”按钮。然后你只是尽可能地把人送到一条直线。我想MapQuest过去称之为最短路线与最快路线。但想象一下你有这个小旋钮
that could decide which one to favor. And the question is, given a lot of routes that people took, you know, what should the setting of the knob be such that you kind of match their behavior? And so when they choose to take the extra step of going to the highway, your algorithm does the same. And that's actually a really, really hard problem to solve. And it gets way harder when you look at sequential. If you're looking at a single decision in isolation, then there's a lot you can do. Then I think actually, when you look at one decision in isolation, then copying the person's behavior is the same as inverse decision making.
可以决定偏向哪一个。问题是，鉴于人们采取的许多路线，你知道，旋钮的设置应该是什么，以便你某种程度上匹配他们的行为？所以当他们选择采取去高速公路的额外步骤时，你的算法也做同样的事情。而这实际上是一个非常非常难解决的问题。当你观察顺序时，它会变得更难。如果你孤立地观察一个决定，那么你可以做很多事情。然后我认为实际上，当你孤立地观察一个决定时，复制人的行为与逆向决策是一样的。
When you have a whole host of decisions and you actually want to copy their strategy, that is a very, very hard problem. That's actually an area of research that my job, my day job is trying to crack some of that. And I can tell you firsthand, it's a super, super hard problem. But ultimately, it's really important because there's value in doing something that a person would have done. If a person would have made a right and then a U-turn, I mean, maybe a left is like 1% safer. But at the end of the day, if that's what people want, then there's value in giving people what they want. You know, the customer is always right, you know.
当你有一大堆决定，而你实际上想复制他们的策略时，那是一个非常非常难的问题。这实际上是一个研究领域，我的工作，我的日常工作正在试图破解其中的一些。我可以第一手告诉你，这是一个超级超级难的问题。但最终，它非常重要，因为做一个人本来会做的事情是有价值的。如果一个人本来会右转然后掉头，我的意思是，也许左转安全1%。但归根结底，如果那是人们想要的，那么给人们他们想要的就有价值。你知道，顾客永远是对的，你知道。
So, you know, understanding what people want and being able to have a human first strategy, that is a phenomenally difficult problem. But I think extremely interesting. Yeah. I think that human first strategy is, is really unique and really important because you can solve a problem, but if, if people can't understand the problem or understand how to apply that problem, that's a different problem. You know, you really haven't solved the problem. And, you know, you, you talked a little bit about what I would call the moment of fine tuning, you know, and because one human being wants to solve a problem this way because the way in which they've grown their organization or their operations is extremely unique. I call them snowflakes, you know, just because they're all unique and wonderful and amazing. And that's the opportunity, too, is to go into an organization and say, you have this beautiful snowflake and we want to make it better. And what's unique to you.
所以，你知道，理解人们想要什么，并能够拥有一个以人为本的策略，那是一个极其困难的问题。但我认为非常有趣。是的。我认为那个以人为本的策略是，非常独特且非常重要，因为你可以解决一个问题，但如果，如果人们不能理解这个问题或理解如何应用那个问题，那是另一个问题。你知道，你真的没有解决这个问题。而且，你知道，你，你谈到了一点我称之为微调时刻的东西，你知道，因为一个人想以这种方式解决问题，因为他们发展组织或运营的方式非常独特。我称他们为雪花，你知道，仅仅因为他们都是独特、美妙和令人惊叹的。这也是机会，去一个组织说，“你有这朵美丽的雪花，我们想让它变得更好。”以及什么是对你独特的。
So you have to have a solution that's very flexible and still really easy to use because there are human beings involved here. They're operators. You know, imagine, you know, you're talking about, you know, knobs and, you know, turning people left and fine tuning that, you know, imagine if they're, you know, probably the first cars that, you know, were very difficult to operate. Even today, most people, at least here in the U.S., they, this probably isn't a shock to some of the world, but if you're driving a stick shift, people in the U.S US may not be able to actually operate that vehicle due to the high complexity, right? Or the non-user friendliness. And inside of our routing solution, as an example, we have the ability to fine tune what you were talking
所以你必须有一个非常灵活且仍然非常易于使用的解决方案，因为这里涉及人类。他们是操作员。你知道，想象一下，你知道，你在谈论，你知道，旋钮和，你知道，把人们向左转并微调那个，你知道，想象如果他们是，你知道，可能是第一批汽车，你知道，操作起来非常困难。即使在今天，大多数人，至少在这里在美国，他们，这对世界上的一些人来说可能不是一个震惊，但如果你在开手动挡，美国的人可能实际上无法操作那辆车，因为高复杂性，对吧？或者非用户友好性。在我们的路由解决方案内部，作为一个例子，我们有能力微调你正在谈论的
about in terms of optimization, but it's really where art meets science. And like you can prioritize distance and prioritize travel time or waiting problems down the line. So if you don't fine tune or prioritize other things or deprioritize them, then you're going to have inefficient routes. I mean, you're already going to introduce an inefficiency, like a time window to a route. So how do you still try to be efficient with all of these constraints and do so in a way that's friendly to a human operator. Like that's the real problem. Yeah. Yeah. You hit the nail on the head. I think stepping back a little bit, I think this is a problem that's challenging the entire field. You know, if you look at a lot of planning, you know, algorithms and systems, a lot of them work
关于优化，但这确实是艺术与科学相遇的地方。就像你可以优先考虑距离，优先考虑旅行时间或排队问题。所以如果你不微调或优先考虑其他事情，或者取消优先考虑它们，那么你将拥有低效的路线。我的意思是，你已经要引入一种低效，比如路线的时间窗口。所以你如何仍然尝试在所有这些约束下保持高效，并以对人类操作员友好的方式这样做？那才是真正的问题。是的。是的。你一针见血。我认为退后一步，我认为这是一个挑战整个领域的问题。你知道，如果你看很多规划，你知道，算法和系统，它们中的很多工作
through search. So, you know, search-based methods. And there's a variety of different things that people out there, if you're interested in this, check out the field is called operations research. And there's a whole host of different things. There's this thing called branch and bound, which is where you try to predict the best and worst case scenarios. And so you take a guess, you're saying, well, you know, I'm in Florida, I need to go to Texas, you know, best case, I'm going to do it in I don't know, 14 hours, right? And so you also say kind of what do you think the worst case is going to be? And then based on that, you can search in kind of a smart way. And that's where you would do something like if I'm on the highway and the grocery store
通过搜索。所以，你知道，基于搜索的方法。而且有各种各样的东西，如果你对此感兴趣，看看这个领域叫运筹学。而且有各种各样的东西。有一种东西叫分支定界法，这是你试图预测最好和最坏情况的地方。所以你做一个猜测，你说，“好吧，你知道，我在佛罗里达，我需要去德克萨斯，你知道，最好的情况，我将在我不知道，14小时内完成它，对吧？”所以你也说某种程度上你认为最坏的情况会是什么。然后基于此，你可以以某种聪明的方式搜索。这就是你会做类似的事情的地方，如果我在高速公路上，而杂货店
is also right off the highway, but 10 miles away, I'm not really going to think about all the exits along the way. I'm just going to go as close as I can and then get off the highway. Because you've bounded a lot of those, like getting off the highway early, you just assume that those are kind of bad ideas. And so for a long time, just kind of circling back a little bit, for a long time, like these two fields were totally, totally separate.
也就在高速公路旁边，但10英里远，我真的不会考虑沿途所有的出口。我只会尽可能靠近，然后下高速公路。因为你限制了其中的很多，比如提前下高速公路，你只是假设那些是某种坏主意。所以很长一段时间，只是某种程度上稍微绕回来，很长一段时间，这两个领域是完全完全分开的。
So the thing we talked about earlier about kind of statistics and kind of copying the way people do it, people being very random, having very random behavior. So you're also inheriting all of that randomness. That's one area. Then you have a separate area over here
所以我们之前谈到的关于某种统计学和某种复制人们做它的方式，人们非常随机，有非常随机的行为。所以你也继承了所有那些随机性。这是一个领域。然后你在这里有一个单独的领域
that's sort of really pristine, that's kind of searching and you have these bounds and you have all this theory that tells you how amazing you are and how all your error is going to like approach zero so quickly. But then it's like, you know, the real world has both. Like you can't just not plan and just at every single step say, what would a person do?
那某种程度上非常原始，某种程度上是搜索，你有这些界限，你有所有这些理论告诉你你有多么惊人，以及你所有的错误将如何如此迅速地趋近于零。但随后就像，你知道，现实世界两者都有。你不能仅仅不规划，并在每一步都说，“一个人会做什么？”
Because people are planning, right? And so if you don't have some kind of planning, you know, this is kind of like if you have a modern iPhone or Android, you know, when you go to type you have a a modern you know iphone or android you know when you go to type something it'll have suggestions right so you can actually type like the and then hit a space and it'll actually suggest things to put there like words to put there and one thing my son one of my kids loves to do is to just hit that over and over again like even with no content he'll hit it and then it'll end up end up generating sentences, but they don't actually make any sense. It's like the parts of speech all fit together and you can read it, but they're totally incoherent. That's what would happen if you
因为人们正在规划，对吧？所以如果你没有某种规划，你知道，这有点像如果你有一个现代iPhone或Android，你知道，当你去打字时，你有一个现代的你知道iPhone或Android，你知道，当你去打字时，它会有建议，对吧？所以你实际上可以打字，比如“the”，然后按一个空格，它实际上会建议放在那里的东西，比如放在那里的词，我儿子，我的一个孩子喜欢做的一件事就是一遍又一遍地按那个，即使没有内容，他也会按它，然后它最终会生成句子，但它们实际上没有任何意义。就像词性都组合在一起，你可以读它，但它们完全不连贯。如果你
had just taken the statistic approach. It's kind of like doing the same thing, but with your car. And so marrying these two things together, right? The higher level planning and the strategy, which expects things to be really kind of pure and clean and deterministic, you know, marrying that with all of the messy statistics and the human reasoning, that is a totally unsolved area. As you said, it's in the realm of the arts. I mean, it's a lot of empiric trial and error. Nobody really knows how to do that in a good way. And even the brightest minds on the planet have really no idea how to marry these two disciplines, despite the fact that the entire world runs on doing exactly that.
只是采取了统计学方法，那就会发生这种情况。这有点像做同样的事情，但用你的车。所以将这两件事结合在一起，对吧？更高级别的规划和策略，它期望事情非常某种程度上纯净、干净和确定性，你知道，将那个与所有混乱的统计学和人类推理结合起来，那是一个完全未解决的领域。正如你所说，它在艺术领域。我的意思是，这是大量的经验试错。没有人真正知道如何以好的方式做到这一点。即使是地球上最聪明的人，也真的不知道如何结合这两个学科，尽管全世界都在做完全相同的事情。
Yeah, it's interesting. Just as an example, it kind of came from the recesses of my brain somewhere, but something about landscape design of all things. But in terms of where if you had to, you know, if you had just a square piece of land connecting, you know, one building to another, where would you put the path or where would you put, you know, the actual path for a human being to walk? And so marrying that art and science and, you know, one school of thought is, well, don't put a path in whatsoever. And the human beings will actually create a path you'll see. And we've all seen this on certain paths, either through campuses or any location that has a path between buildings. You've seen where someone took a little shortcut and enough people take that shortcut. It creates its own path and it's not the original intended
是的，这很有趣。只是作为一个例子，它某种程度上来自我大脑的某个深处，但关于景观设计的东西。但就如果你必须，你知道，如果你只有一块方形的土地连接，你知道，一栋建筑到另一栋，你会把路径放在哪里，或者你会把，你知道，人类行走的实际路径放在哪里？所以结合那种艺术和科学，而且，你知道，一种思想流派是，好吧，根本不要放路径。而人类实际上会创造一条你会看到的路径。我们都在某些路径上看到过这一点，无论是通过校园还是任何在建筑物之间有路径的位置。你已经看到有人走了个小捷径，足够多的人走了那个捷径。它创造了它自己的路径，而且它不是最初预期的
path, but it's what a human being would have done. And so if you'd left that empty and maybe just walked and put the paths in where the humans would be a totally different thing. But at the same time, maybe you wouldn't end up with paths at all. So it's, I don't know, kind of making me think about that in that sense, just from a, you know, you have to put paths in at the same time you have human beings that are going to influence where they actually go. Yeah. Yeah. I remember, um, I'm a big fan of Tarn Adams, who is actually a video game developer, but it's a very esoteric video game developer. He has a PhD in math. And so he makes these really deep simulations. And actually for the past, I think like 15 years, he's been working on one game, the same game for one and a half decades called dwarf
路径，但那是人类会做的事情。所以如果你把它留空，也许只是走走，把路径放在人类会走的地方，那将是完全不同的事情。但与此同时，也许你根本不会得到路径。所以它，我不知道，某种程度上让我在这方面思考它，只是从一个，你知道，你必须放入路径，同时你有会影响他们实际去哪里的人类。是的。是的。我记得，嗯，我是Tarn Adams的忠实粉丝，他实际上是一个视频游戏开发者，但他是一个非常深奥的视频游戏开发者。他有数学博士学位。所以他制作这些非常深刻的模拟。而且实际上在过去，我想大约15年，他一直在开发一个游戏，同一个游戏，长达一个半十年，叫《矮人
fortress where you at a high level you control or maybe control is even the right word but like you influence you know a whole army a whole city of of dwarves and so you need to sort of build homes for these dwarves and you And it's a whole simulation. But one of the things that's really interesting is he was faced with this problem of he has potentially thousands of units in this game. And the units are very egocentric. In most games, imagine Doom, right? So in Doom, all the enemies are trying to kill you and so you can actually just get your path to everything and just flip those paths and now you have all the ways for the monsters to come after you and it's very straightforward because they're only interested
要塞》（Dwarf Fortress），在那里你在高层面上你控制，或者也许控制甚至不是正确的词，但就像你影响，你知道，整个军队，整个城市，矮人，所以你需要某种程度上为这些矮人建造家园，你而且这是一个完整的模拟。但真正有趣的事情之一是，他面临着这个问题，他在这个游戏中可能有成千上万个单位。而且单位非常以自我为中心。在大多数游戏中，想象《毁灭战士》（Doom），对吧？所以在《毁灭战士》中，所有的敌人都在试图杀死你，所以你实际上可以只是得到你到一切的路径，并翻转那些路径，现在你有了怪物来追你的所有方式，而且非常直接，因为他们只对
in one thing but in dwarf fortress as i said you're not really you're not really controlling any of these citizens. They're all doing their own thing, but they're modeled at a very fine granularity. And so they're all egocentric and they all have different things they want to do at different times. And he struggled a lot with route planning for his game. And the thing that actually, you know, let's say cracked it for him or made it to where he could move on to something else was this idea of basically almost like an ant pheromone trail type thing. Every time a dwarf steps on a square or every time a dwarf, you know, walks a path, he, you know, increments some value and it makes that path more valuable. I think the ants might be a good
一件事感兴趣，但在《矮人要塞》中，正如我所说，你并不是真的在控制任何这些公民。他们都在做他们自己的事情，但他们是在非常精细的粒度上建模的。所以他们都是以自我为中心的，他们都有不同的事情想在不同的时间做。他在他的游戏中为路线规划挣扎了很多。而实际上，你知道，可以这么说，为他破解了它，或者使它达到他可以继续做其他事情的程度的东西，是这个基本上几乎像蚂蚁信息素踪迹那样的想法。每次矮人踩在一个方格上，或者每次矮人，你知道，走一条路径，他，你知道，增加一些值，它使那条路径更有价值。我想蚂蚁可能是一个很好的
metaphor here. Imagine if you have a set of ants and they're just constantly leaving kind of a little pheromone chemical trails. Well, if all the ants are kind of doing the same kind of routine, then certain paths, as you said, will emerge. Or even people on a college campus, if there are no roads, they'll eventually all start. If a lot of people are going between the math and the science buildings, they'll start to erode that terrain and the path will start to emerge that way. And so then you could say, well, okay, everywhere I see the grass eroded, I'm going to start laying bricks there or I'm going to think that's the right way to go. And so using kind of that trick, Tard was able to, to get the path planning. But again, you know, that trick has problems as well. And so it's, it's still an art form. It still requires a lot
隐喻。想象如果你有一群蚂蚁，它们只是不断地留下某种小信息素化学踪迹。好吧，如果所有的蚂蚁都在做同样的那种例行公事，那么某些路径，正如你所说，就会出现。或者甚至是大学校园里的人，如果没有路，他们最终都会开始。如果很多人在数学和科学大楼之间走动，他们就会开始侵蚀那片地形，路径就会以那种方式开始出现。所以然后你可以说，“好吧，好的，我看到草地被侵蚀的任何地方，我都要开始在那里铺砖，或者我认为那是正确的方向。”所以使用那种技巧，Tard能够，去进行路径规划。但再说一次，你知道，那个技巧也有问题。所以它，它仍然是一种艺术形式。它仍然需要很多
of tuning, but yeah, even in, in simulation, it's, it's definitely not a solved problem. It's about environment too, right? So that kind of reminds me that, you know, in terms of, at least in the, in the US and most cities, you know, you're actually laid out roads are kind of block by block. I mean, we have literal blocks and, you cities didn't typically evolve with the automobile and they didn't evolve with the city planning, right? So they didn't have that map. So it sounds like, you know, that, you know, trail, if you look at an ant's trail is oftentimes not straight, it's not, you know, linear, it's not following that same path. So the European path in that environment is very different than the U S environment. And it's always been funny to me when, you know, if you start to talk to any European, I mean, even if you know nothing about route planning, you could probably have a conversation on how the cities are laid out and planned and how different they are and how they have to think differently in terms of, you know, actually route planning or just getting around town is very, very different versus our very highway driven culture. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. Cool. Yeah. This is absolutely fascinating. You know, there's so many directions,
调整，但是的，即使在，在模拟中，它，它绝对不是一个已解决的问题。它也关于环境，对吧？所以这某种程度上提醒我，你知道，至少在，在美国和大多数城市，你知道，你实际上铺设的道路是某种程度上逐个街区的。我的意思是，我们有字面上的街区，而且，城市通常不是随着汽车进化的，它们也不是随着城市规划进化的，对吧？所以它们没有那张地图。所以听起来，你知道，那个，你知道，踪迹，如果你看蚂蚁的踪迹，往往不是直的，它不是，你知道，线性的，它不是遵循那条相同的路径。所以那个环境中的欧洲路径与美国环境非常不同。而且对我来说一直很有趣，当，你知道，如果你开始和任何欧洲人交谈，我的意思是，即使你对路线规划一无所知，你可能也能就城市是如何布局和规划的，以及它们有多么不同，以及它们在，你知道，实际路线规划或仅仅是在城里走动方面必须如何不同地思考，进行对话，这与我们非常依赖高速公路的文化非常非常不同。是的。是的。这说得通。酷。是的。这绝对令人着迷。你知道，有太多的方向，
but let's take a little moment here and talk a bit about Route for Me. So what is Route for Me? Is it an app or a service or, you know, what is, is sort of the vehicle, no pun intended, that you use to sort of deliver, deliver these routes? And what is that whole product like? Sure. The, the vehicle is, it's a web in mobile, both Android and iOS application. And so really it's a route planning and route optimization application. So anyone today can actually go onto the Apple store, the Google play store, download the route for me app and plan a route, plan a multi-stop route. Of course you can plan just one, two, three stops,
但让我们花点时间聊聊 Route for Me。Route for Me 到底是什么？它是一个应用程序、一项服务，还是说，你用什么工具——请原谅我用这个词——来交付这些路线？整个产品是什么样的？当然。这个工具是一个网页和移动端应用，同时支持 Android 和 iOS。它本质上是一个路线规划和路线优化应用程序。所以今天任何人都可以去 Apple Store 或 Google Play Store 下载 Route for Me 应用，并规划一条路线，一条多停靠点的路线。当然，你也可以只规划一、二、三个停靠点，
and it is a free app. There is a paid version. So we have a lot of mobile users. And then for our business users, they're typically going to want to plan their, for example, next day deliveries, same day deliveries or service type businesses that will use it to plan their routes and optimize their routes for ultimate efficiency so that they're spending less gas. At the end of the day, that's really core to what we want to do and help with is to help save the world and make the world a little bit better place for our children and more efficient and save those trees. It's really core to my heart. And I'm really happy that the company's followed that path all along to make the world a little bit better place through software, which is something I never thought I would be in. But I'm so happy that I am at the end of the day. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. What about folks who are enterprise, you know, who might have their own
而且它是一个免费应用。也有付费版本。我们有很多移动端用户。对于我们的企业用户，他们通常需要规划例如次日送达、当日送达的路线，或者服务型企业会用它来规划和优化路线，以实现极致的效率，从而减少燃油消耗。归根结底，这正是我们想要做和提供帮助的核心，即帮助拯救世界，为我们的孩子创造一个更美好的世界，提高效率并保护树木。这真的是我内心深处的核心理念。我很高兴公司一直沿着这条道路前进，通过软件让世界变得更美好，这是我从未想过自己会从事的领域。但我很高兴最终我身处其中。是的，这很有道理。那么那些企业用户呢，他们可能有自己的
app or something? Do you have an API for those folks or how does that work? Yeah, absolutely. So our API documentation is at routeforme.io. And if you want to go there, you can also check out even benchmarks against some of the different world record in terms of times of solving. If you've got a route for me.io forward slash benchmarks, that's a really great place to kind of see some data that our API is available. If you want to get an API key at a rough for me.io. Cool. So yeah, explain a little bit about what the free version is like, like what's the pricing model like and how does that work? So we have a mobile only subscription.
应用程序之类的？你们为这些人提供 API 吗，或者它是如何运作的？是的，当然。我们的 API 文档在 routeforme.io。如果你想去看看，甚至可以查看我们与一些不同世界纪录在求解时间方面的基准测试。如果你访问 routeforme.io/benchmarks，那是一个非常好的地方，可以查看我们 API 的一些可用数据。如果你想获取 API 密钥，可以访问 routeforme.io。太棒了。那么，解释一下免费版本是什么样的，定价模式是怎样的，它是如何运作的？我们有一个仅限移动端的订阅。
And so that's where a lot of our users come in who are actually part of very large organizations and they're kind of given tasks and they say, okay, well, I've got 50 deliveries to go to, 100, 200. And they spend the time to actually input those into the system because they know that time up front is going to make them actually much more efficient throughout the route than just kind of trying to figure it out. So many of our mobile users come in and it's a subscription base if you want to plan more routes than the free version allows you to. And so there's the mobile only. And then the web is more for when a business recognizes that, hey, you know what, my drivers are already doing this.
这就是我们很多用户的来源，他们实际上是大型组织的一部分，他们被分配了任务，他们说，好吧，我有 50 个、100 个、200 个送货点。他们花时间把这些输入系统，因为他们知道预先投入的时间会让他们在整个路线中比盲目摸索要高效得多。所以我们很多移动端用户都是这样进来的，如果你想规划比免费版本允许的更多的路线，就需要订阅。这就是仅限移动端的版本。而网页版则更多是针对那些意识到“嘿，我的司机已经在做这件事了”的企业，
I can help them be more efficient. I can also gain control back into the business to understand what they should be doing versus what they're actually doing. So we can hook into various GPS telematics solutions, as well as the GPS telematics on the actual mobile device itself. So we can give a really, really nice plan on the web to say, Hey, here's what the drivers should be doing. And here's what they're actually doing. So you can overlay the planned route with the actual route, you know, that's been performed. And instead of, you know, just making assumptions that everything's getting done correctly, or when a customer calls up and you don't know what's happening in the field, you can actually make a decision very
我可以帮助他们提高效率。我还可以重新获得对业务的控制权，了解他们应该做什么，而不是他们实际上在做什么。因此，我们可以连接到各种 GPS 远程信息处理解决方案，以及移动设备本身的 GPS 远程信息处理。这样我们就可以在网页上提供一个非常非常好的计划，说明“嘿，司机应该做什么，他们实际上在做什么”。所以你可以将计划路线与实际执行的路线进行叠加。而不是仅仅假设一切都做得很好，或者当客户打电话来而你不知道现场发生了什么时，你实际上可以非常
quickly by looking on the web in that screen, just to say, Oh, it looks like they're running a little bit late. And we've even built some other things on top of that, that kind of eliminate that problem. So you probably get a lot of notifications. If you get any kind of deliveries or service done, you know, you always want to know as a consumer, as a customer, you know, when that's going to happen. You know, if you order some new furniture, you know, you don't want to sit around for the four hour window that they give you. So the companies that are adopting technologies that are kind of making an Uber like experience for customers to get a text notification, to be able to see the vehicle coming to them on the map. And that's kind of what we're doing in order to enable, you know, small, medium and large and enterprise businesses to do that rapidly at scale. So it's a very exciting thing. And I think just for everyone involved in the whole cycle,
快速地通过查看网页上的屏幕做出决定，比如，“哦，看起来他们有点晚了”。我们甚至在上面构建了一些其他东西来消除这个问题。所以你可能会收到很多通知。如果你有任何送货或服务，作为消费者或客户，你总是想知道什么时候会发生。如果你订购了一些新家具，你肯定不想坐在那里等他们给你的四个小时窗口。所以那些采用技术的公司正在为客户创造一种类似 Uber 的体验，让他们收到短信通知，能够在地图上看到车辆向他们驶来。这就是我们正在做的事情，以便使小型、中型、大型和企业级业务能够快速、大规模地实现这一点。所以这是一件非常令人兴奋的事情。而且我认为对于整个周期中的每个人来说，
it's something that makes their lives better. Cool. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. So what is the app experience like? So someone says, here's my 10 locations and route for me, we'll find a route for them. And then do you, do you then hand them off to like a, their, you know, maps app of choice, or, or do you also do all of the, the navigation along the way? So we want to present the user with the best experience and how they want to experience it. Because again, they're all unique, you know, they're, they're my snowflakes, right? Every customer I've worked with, you know, everything's a little bit different. And you mentioned something, okay, we've got the data. That's usually the first step. And sometimes that's the hardest step is to make sure that we
这让他们的生活变得更美好。太酷了。是的，这非常有道理。那么应用体验是怎样的？如果有人说，这是我的 10 个地点，Route for Me 会为他们找到一条路线。然后你们是把他们交给他们选择的地图应用，还是你们也负责全程的导航？我们希望为用户提供他们想要的最佳体验。因为同样，他们都是独一无二的，他们就像我的雪花一样，对吧？我合作过的每个客户，每件事都有点不同。你提到了数据，这通常是第一步。有时这是最难的一步，即确保我们
get the data in a usable format. Oftentimes, you know, the first step is transitioning from cocktail napkins to using something like a spreadsheet and getting them to a point where, okay, you know, many companies are already there. Some are using different systems, ERPs, you know, order management systems. And so it's just a matter of getting data in the right format that's consumable. And that can, once we're there, it's really just a matter of upload that and get the settings that are needed for the actual route or routes and this allowing the user to make changes. That's really critically important because, you know, just because we say, Hey, this is what is the solution. Well, you may have that internal tribal knowledge that says no i want to take these three stops and put them on this route so i drag and drop and from there you can just very quickly approve the routes and dispatch them to the mobile device so when they're playing on
以可用的格式获取数据。通常，第一步是从鸡尾酒餐巾纸过渡到使用电子表格之类的东西，并让他们达到一个点，即“好的，许多公司已经做到了”。有些公司正在使用不同的系统，ERP，订单管理系统。所以这只是一个将数据转换为正确、可消费格式的问题。一旦到了那一步，就只需要上传它并获取实际路线所需的设置，并允许用户进行更改。这非常关键，因为仅仅因为我们说“嘿，这就是解决方案”，你可能拥有内部的部落知识，说“不，我想把这三个停靠点放在这条路线上”，所以我拖放它们，从那里你可以非常快速地批准路线并将其分派到移动设备，所以当他们在
the web it's dispatched right to the mobile device and the driver can follow it again a very easy to use application go download it check it out let And, you know, so the drivers can perform a number of other actions from marking an address is visited and departed to adding a note, signature capture, images, various other actions that they can involve. And then there's feedback as well. So we can automatically detect when a location is visited, departed based on geofences around a location so that we know that they're on time ahead behind. So it's giving that feedback to the rest of the people back at, you know, HQ to understand, Hey, are we actually on time? Are we doing what we said we do? And so it's a very simple transition for the driver. And we really focus a lot on the drivers.
网页上规划时，它会直接分派到移动设备，司机可以再次跟随它，这是一个非常易于使用的应用程序，去下载它看看吧。而且，司机可以执行许多其他操作，从标记地址为已访问和已离开，到添加备注、签名捕获、图像以及他们可以参与的其他各种操作。然后还有反馈。我们可以根据位置周围的地理围栏自动检测何时访问、何时离开，这样我们就知道他们是准时、提前还是落后。所以它向总部的人员提供反馈，以了解“嘿，我们真的准时吗？我们在做我们说要做的事情吗？”所以这对司机来说是一个非常简单的过渡。我们确实非常关注司机。
That's, that's really our main focus is if we can create a really great experience for the drivers that's critically important because of course you know the web is very friendly but it's a very quick process of planning the routes you know the driver is the one that's actually doing it all day so if they uh want to hook into so on the mobile app if there's 10 stops for their route and here's the sequence of the stops all All they have to do is click on, you know, a little icon and they can save it as a default. If they want to use Waze, they can use Waze. They want to use our in-app navigation, they can use our in-app navigation. So we present them with choices because we think it's the right thing to do. Yeah, totally makes sense. Totally makes sense. Very cool. And so what, jumping a little bit to Route4Me as a company. So you said that you've been, Route4Me has been sort of remote first, almost since the beginning. And so what is
这是我们主要的关注点，如果我们能为司机创造一种非常棒的体验，那是非常关键的，因为当然，你知道网页非常友好，但规划路线的过程非常快，司机才是整天都在做这件事的人，所以如果他们想连接到……所以在移动应用上，如果他们的路线有 10 个停靠点，这是停靠点的顺序，他们所要做的就是点击一个小图标，他们就可以将其保存为默认设置。如果他们想使用 Waze，他们可以使用 Waze。如果他们想使用我们的应用内导航，他们可以使用我们的应用内导航。所以我们为他们提供选择，因为我们认为这是正确的做法。是的，完全有道理。完全有道理。非常酷。那么，跳跃一下，谈谈作为公司的 Route4Me。你说 Route4Me 几乎从一开始就是远程优先的。那么
that like? Do you have folks all over the world? Do you have like, what do you have a huge- Every time zone. Time zone. Yeah. So how do you navigate all of that? How do you deal with people who are, you know, you have a meeting with somebody in Sweden and someone in Tokyo, you know, it's kind of, how do you kind of get, be productive in that kind of global environment? It's, well, I think there's flexibility. And so there's a give and take to everything. And there's also, I'd say there's more silos, you know, in terms of within the company
那是怎样的体验？你们在世界各地都有员工吗？你们有巨大的……每个时区都有。时区。是的。那么你们是如何处理所有这些的？你们如何处理那些……你和瑞典的人开会，和东京的人开会，这有点……你们如何在那种全球环境中保持高效？嗯，我认为有灵活性。凡事都有妥协。而且，我想公司内部会有更多的孤岛，
itself that you can't have just, you know, all of the product team, you know, necessarily all on different time zones at the same time, it's really, you know, again, using other software solutions to actually product manage it. So everyone can get assigned work and that work can get done. And, you know, so it's just a matter of making sure that that's being done, you know, from a project management perspective, you know, it's kind of interesting because, you know, the whole idea of time zones, you know, as long as the work's getting done, that's really, that's really what we care about at Raw for me, like do, do good work and do well and get the work done and just move on. There's no need to necessarily have a meeting about this as long as we can clearly
你不能让所有的产品团队都在同一时间处于不同的时区，这确实是……同样，使用其他软件解决方案来进行产品管理。所以每个人都可以被分配工作，工作可以完成。所以这只是确保工作完成的问题，从项目管理的角度来看，这很有趣，因为时区的整个概念，只要工作完成了，这才是我们在 Route for Me 真正关心的，做好工作，做得好，完成工作，然后继续前进。只要我们能清楚地
communicate. So I think that's probably the really big thing is communication. And there are a lot of tools from Slack to Skype to HipChat. I mean, there's all kinds of tools for communication to Zoom, as we've all found, you know, throughout this pandemic, you know, there's many ways to keep in touch and the time zones are one thing. And we do have some folks who, you know, shifted their time zones and because they believe in what we're doing and the work that we're doing and, you know, it's great for them. So they may be in the European time zone and working a little bit more in the Eastern time zone. So it's just somehow it works. People find a way.
沟通，就没有必要一定要开会。所以我认为这可能是非常重要的一点，就是沟通。有很多工具，从 Slack 到 Skype 再到 HipChat。我的意思是，有很多沟通工具，还有 Zoom，正如我们在整个疫情期间发现的那样，有很多保持联系的方式，时区是一回事。我们确实有一些员工，他们调整了自己的时区，因为他们相信我们正在做的事情以及我们所做的工作，这对他们来说很好。所以他们可能在欧洲时区，工作时间更多地向东部时区靠拢。所以不知何故它奏效了。人们找到了方法。
I couldn't give you the exact recipe or formula because I think it's unique to every business. And it's just what you find in what is so amazing about businesses and building products is that they're all unique. The way we do it may not work for another company. Yeah, that makes sense. So you were remote before COVID. And one thing I've always been curious because, you know, we weren't remote before COVID is, do you have like a, maybe like an all hands meeting in person? Like, do you all get together in a central place maybe once a year? And how magical is that, right? I mean, just to get to see everyone in the same room. I think that would be pretty amazing.
我无法给你确切的配方或公式，因为我认为这对每家企业都是独一无二的。这就是你在企业和产品构建中发现的如此令人惊奇的事情，它们都是独一无二的。我们做事的方式可能不适用于另一家公司。是的，这很有道理。所以你们在新冠疫情之前就是远程办公的。我一直很好奇的一件事是，因为我们在新冠疫情之前不是远程办公的，你们是否有类似面对面的全员会议？你们是否每年在某个中心地点聚在一起？那有多神奇，对吧？我的意思是，能看到每个人都在同一个房间里。我想那会非常棒。
It is magical. Funny enough, when I started at Route for me and I was working closely with some folks and I actually didn't meet anyone for like two and a half years, like in person. Wow. Which seems crazy. And it's, it was partly the, the, you know, the stage of growth we were at. And, but now people come to the organization and we do see each other in person a little bit, you know, obviously with COVID there's, that hasn't been the case, but I remember someone coming into the organization and
这确实很神奇。有趣的是，当我刚开始在 Route for Me 工作时，我和一些人密切合作，但我实际上有两年半的时间没有见过任何人，面对面地。哇。这看起来很疯狂。这部分是因为我们所处的增长阶段。但现在人们来到组织，我们确实会面对面地见到彼此，你知道，显然由于新冠疫情，情况并非如此，但我记得有人来到组织，
meeting Dan and George, our co-founders within like the first week. And I was like, man, it took me like three years. So, you know, the pace, the pace of things is, and it's wonderful to see. It's just kind of, sometimes you sit back and, you know, you can't, you can't really put that on someone, you know, to kind of appreciate it, but I certainly appreciate it today. Yeah, that makes sense. So, so for folks out there who are interested in, you know, joining Route for Me, what are sort of the opportunities available? Do you have internships? Do you have full-time positions?
在第一周内就见到了我们的联合创始人 Dan 和 George。我当时想，天哪，我花了三年时间。所以，事情的节奏是……看到这些真是太好了。有时你坐下来，你真的不能把这种感觉强加给别人，让他们去体会，但我今天确实很感激。是的，这很有道理。所以，对于那些有兴趣加入 Route for Me 的人，有哪些机会？你们有实习生吗？你们有全职职位吗？
And so what kind of folks are you looking for? We do have internships. We are actively hiring. And, you know, I would say that that's, in terms of what we're looking for in terms of folks, it's someone who, you know, believes in what we're doing. And I think that's in terms of what we're looking for in terms of folks, it's someone who, you know, believes in what we're doing. And I think that's just really critical. And, you know, from our perspective, we really are on a mission to save the world.
你们在寻找什么样的人？我们确实有实习生。我们正在积极招聘。而且，我想说，就我们寻找的人才而言，是那些相信我们正在做的事情的人。我认为这是……就我们寻找的人才而言，是那些相信我们正在做的事情的人。我认为这真的非常关键。而且，从我们的角度来看，我们确实肩负着拯救世界的使命。
So if you want to join that mission, as much as it may sound, you know, a lot of people may kind of say, you know, oh, that's childish or, oh, that's, you know, way too big. I think everyone has an opportunity to make an impact. And so from the perspective of developers, we're always looking for developers. And then we're also hiring in many other roles as well from even just support. I think, you know, that's a wonderful opportunity to get your foot in a door and start to understand what are these problems that, you know, businesses and people are facing on a daily basis and how can we help them?
所以如果你想加入这个使命，尽管听起来可能很多人会说，哦，那太幼稚了，或者哦，那太宏大了。我认为每个人都有机会产生影响。所以从开发人员的角度来看，我们一直在寻找开发人员。而且我们也在许多其他角色中招聘，甚至只是支持岗位。我认为这是一个很好的机会，可以让你迈出第一步，开始了解企业和人们每天面临的问题，以及我们如何帮助他们？
Cool. That makes sense. I think a couple of things that we touched on was the API. And so I believe you mentioned routeforme.io. That's a place for developers to check out API. But you also have routeforme.com, right? Unless it's somebody else. Yeah, routeforme.com is our main website. So if you want to go start a web trial,
酷。这很有道理。我想我们谈到的几件事是 API。我相信你提到了 routeforme.io。那是开发人员查看 API 的地方。但你们也有 routeforme.com，对吧？除非是别人。是的，routeforme.com 是我们的主网站。所以如果你想开始网页试用，
you can start a free web trial, which includes access to the web and to the mobile apps. You can also just download our mobile app straight from the app store, either the iOS Apple store or the Google Play store and start a mobile trial as well, or just download the free mobile app and use that. I think it enables a certain amount of free routes per month and just play around with it if you'd like to mess around. But route4me.com is kind of our main site for the actual productized service of the technology. Cool. Cool. That makes sense. So yeah, everyone check that out. It's got a free trial. You could try different routes. You could play with the API. I think it'd be really fun. I think it's a good experience to try out this tech. And then even if you're doing something simple, like figuring out how to route,
你可以开始免费的网页试用，其中包括对网页和移动应用的访问。你也可以直接从应用商店下载我们的移动应用，无论是 iOS Apple Store 还是 Google Play Store，并开始移动端试用，或者只是下载免费的移动应用并使用它。我认为它每月允许一定数量的免费路线，如果你想尝试一下，可以随便玩玩。但 route4me.com 是我们实际产品化技术服务的核心网站。酷。酷。这很有道理。所以，每个人都去看看吧。它有免费试用。你可以尝试不同的路线。你可以玩玩 API。我认为这会非常有趣。我认为尝试这种技术是一种很好的体验。即使你做一些简单的事情，比如弄清楚如何规划路线，
plan out, as you said, visiting different houses, your apartment hunting in college or something like that, you could give this a crack. And I think you'll learn a lot along the way. And one opportunity is there's so many really wonderful organizations out there that do a lot of work to underserved communities and underserved populations. I'm really proud that we partner with those communities to help them get access to our software. And so from delivering meals to the needy to, there know, there's a lot of different programs and organizations. So you could always find a little niche if you want to get some experience and just kind of say, Hey, I've got this organization and we want to help them. And
正如你所说，访问不同的房子，你在大学里找公寓之类的，你可以尝试一下。我认为你会在此过程中学到很多东西。有一个机会是，外面有这么多非常棒的组织，为服务不足的社区和服务不足的人群做了很多工作。我真的很自豪我们与这些社区合作，帮助他们获得我们的软件。所以从为有需要的人送餐到……你知道，有很多不同的项目和组织。所以如果你想获得一些经验，并且只是想说，“嘿，我有这个组织，我们想帮助他们”，你总是可以找到一个小众领域。
it's a really great cause get in contact with us. We'd be more than happy to help. It's really our mission to make the world a better place and save the world. And so whether it's through the APIs or even just the web platform, I mean, we've helped delivered a lot of Thanksgiving turkeys to people who otherwise wouldn't have them. And so we're really, really proud of that. So get your hands dirty, get involved, find a way to help people and we'll find a way to help you as well. Cool. Cool. Do you have a preferred sort of social media for people who want to reach out to you, either like a Twitter handle or a LinkedIn? Should people try and find you on LinkedIn? What's sort of your best kind of POC, point of contact? Sure. I mean, of course you can email me, parker at route4me.com. LinkedIn's
这是一个非常好的事业，请联系我们。我们非常乐意提供帮助。让世界变得更美好并拯救世界确实是我们的使命。所以无论是通过 API 还是仅仅通过网页平台，我的意思是，我们已经帮助向那些本来没有火鸡的人运送了很多感恩节火鸡。所以我们对此感到非常非常自豪。所以动手吧，参与进来，找到帮助人们的方法，我们也会找到帮助你的方法。酷。酷。对于那些想联系你的人，你是否有首选的社交媒体，比如 Twitter 账号或 LinkedIn？人们应该尝试在 LinkedIn 上找到你吗？什么是你最好的联系方式？当然。我的意思是，当然你可以给我发电子邮件，parker@route4me.com。LinkedIn
probably the best place to find me. So linkedin.com forward slash Parker Woodward. I think I grabbed that one and connect with me. I'd be happy to connect. And I don't tweet, don't do the Twitter just because, you know, I've got too many, too many luxuries becoming necessities nowadays. I can't keep up with it. Yeah. You don't, you don't have the Twitter appliance. Yeah. There are, there are appliances, aren't there? No, not yet. I suppose. I'd rather have an authentic voice as long as I can. All right, cool. That's awesome.
可能是找到我最好的地方。所以 linkedin.com/ParkerWoodward。我想我抢到了那个，和我联系吧。我很乐意建立联系。我不发推文，不用 Twitter，只是因为，你知道，如今我有太多的奢侈品变成了必需品。我跟不上它。是的。你没有 Twitter 设备。是的。有设备，不是吗？不，还没有。我想。只要我能，我宁愿拥有一个真实的声音。好的，酷。那太棒了。
Yeah, this was amazing. You know, we really dove in deep on how this stuff works. I think people, I mean, I'm sure people will get an appreciation for just like how incredibly complicated this technology is. And it's amazing that you've made it so accessible to so many people. But we've also given people, you know, the tip of the iceberg so they could really dive in deep on the technology and, you know, really learn a lot of those really niche skills that I think are going to become even more important over time. As I say, software eats the world and then AI eats software.
是的，这太棒了。你知道，我们真的深入探讨了这些东西是如何运作的。我想人们，我的意思是，我相信人们会体会到这项技术是多么极其复杂。而且你们能让这么多人如此容易地使用它，这真是太神奇了。但我们也给了人们冰山一角，这样他们就可以真正深入研究这项技术，并真正学习很多我认为随着时间的推移会变得更加重要的利基技能。正如我所说，软件吞噬世界，然后人工智能吞噬软件。
And so, or machine learning maybe eats software. And so this is right at the heart of some really cutting edge tech that I think is super, super exciting. So thank you so much, Parker, for coming on the show. I really appreciate it. Yeah, thanks, Jason. It was a pleasure. And thanks everybody for supporting
所以，或者机器学习可能吞噬软件。所以这正处于一些非常尖端技术的核心，我认为这超级超级令人兴奋。所以非常感谢你，Parker，来到节目中。我真的很感激。是的，谢谢，Jason。这是我的荣幸。也感谢大家支持
the show on Patreon and on our other platforms and checking out our books of the show when we do that. So thanks for your support. I'm sure you've noticed by now we have moved to two shows a month. And so we're able to sort of ramp up production, reach a whole bunch of new folks out there. And so if you're new to the show, you know, welcome. You know, you can always email us. You just go to programmingthrowdown.com and there's a link where you can reach out to us, give us show ideas, connect us to people who would make for fascinating interviews. And just don't hesitate to reach out and say hi. We also have a Discord with an active chat going. A lot
节目在 Patreon 和我们的其他平台上，并在我们这样做时查看我们的节目书籍。所以感谢你们的支持。我相信你们现在已经注意到我们已经改为每月两期节目了。所以我们能够增加产量，接触到外面的一大群新朋友。所以如果你是节目的新听众，欢迎。你知道，你可以随时给我们发电子邮件。你只需访问 programmingthrowdown.com，那里有一个链接，你可以联系我们，给我们提供节目创意，联系那些会进行精彩采访的人。不要犹豫，联系我们打个招呼。我们还有一个 Discord，里面有活跃的聊天。很多
of people talking about jobs, announcing jobs, looking for jobs. There's a lot of active discussion as well on Discord. But thank you so much for supporting the show. And we'll see you all in two weeks. music by eric farmbell programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人在谈论工作、发布工作、寻找工作。Discord 上也有很多活跃的讨论。但非常感谢你们支持这个节目。我们两周后再见。音乐由 Eric Farmbell 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。